[Music]
hello everybody it is Wednesday August
9th it is in fact a little rainy out
here in Los Angeles
yeah it's actually a beautiful
summer day a little overcast but it's a
beautiful 80 degrees a little bit
drizzle
kind of surprised me that it's raining
out here but that's what it is
August
uh today this episode is sponsored by
nobody
my viewers like you
Chino
[Music]
I like my coffee tart
I gotta feel like Al Pacino
together we're stronger together we're
stronger
probably should have kept that to
yourself my guy
my guy
[Music]
um
wow
oh and then we still oh the filter drops
away
stunning beautiful collaboration by uh
Zach and Ian as usual tremendous stuff
here guys thank you I said today's
episode was not sponsored but that's not
quite true is it because tomorrow
Teddy fresh has come out with a new
collection that is honestly so okay
first of all so nice this shirt
hmm
so nice
Harry love how you love in that shirt
it's sick dude so clean thanks bro
anyone perfect colors these are my
colors and it fits this finish oh great
and it's like um Coast is like a nice
Harry Terry yeah everything I think
that's what it is yeah
anyone else rocking uh some tips right
here dude let's see oh yeah that's also
a Terry one isn't it I I it fits me so
well like it's for the perfect fit for
me oh Lena come here Lena's got oh Jesus
Shredder Shredder
he's still alive folks
yes I love that shirt too
okay girl you wear them baggy
yeah so that's a nice shirt that's
coming out long sleeve uh anyone else
I'm wearing one of the sweaters I think
everybody's wearing Dan's got the iconic
classic that's not part of this
collection but it might be on the
website
or a new color or something Dan oh you
got the jacket oh you got the undershirt
yeah
you can't really see the details this is
what she's wearing it's really so sick
dude every time the collection gets
nicer and nicer and then oh oh Olivia
has the uh iconic vintage denim look yes
anyone else I was gonna wait till Friday
to wear mine but it's so beautiful I'm
gonna put it on now okay we love that
you take that Robert Smith [__] off
right now oh this jacket is sick
it's the same patterns that Zach but
it's like on a bomber jacket I love it
it's nice we got the bucket hat also
just came out there's the bucket the
bomber oh this shirt is I was gonna wear
this but I can't because it has green in
it
but uh oh and crushing it with the socks
hello
teddyfresh.com okay
rocking the denim my friend
love that cheers my dude oh [__] what
yo I need that one
oh you're that's the one you're wearing
cam yes
yes dude love that perfect for a day
like today a little drizzle for chisel
loving this piece it's a skirt shirt
actually and I know his songs is this is
the one he's Gonna Wanna want for sure
because it's for the ladies
uh you know dress shirt with all kinds
of fun stuff I will accomplish nothing
today I think that's a restock
this sweater is also a restock I think
oh that's looking good color block uh
uh sweater
Church
jacket
jacket off soccer mom shirt High fashion
stuff guys don't look away
there's more Jesus uh these are bucket
hats
cool shirts that's what Lena was wearing
in a different colorway
oh the chunky didn't I see someone
wearing this
but no Lino's in a shirt she took it off
yeah got it
oh yeah dude come on stand back Louis
Vuitton Gucci there's a new
pattern in town that's right
oh mesh that's kind of fire Zach would
you wear that I would wear that it's
[__] dope I want to see your nipples
under your [__] maybe I shouldn't say
that maybe no I got I got good nibs I
got good nibs you got nice yeah yeah
good and uh just a little graphic tee
and that's it so thank you guys that's
all coming out tomorrow wow what a
spread at 10 A.M PST that's Teddy fresh
thank you and well done to the teddy
fresh team
all right we got a fair bit of things to
talk about here we got a good show here
which is you know
a welcome respite and it's a rainy day
in Los Angeles
so yesterday I did Howie's show which
was his first ever live show and I oh
and I kept asking how are you sure are
you sure you want me to be your first
Live guest
because in my studio I have two buttons
for me and my executive producer
erase the last 30 seconds
they seem to think that I was the one to
go live with
and uh we did I think there was a few
moments there he would have liked to
have cut if he could have yeah what what
was the logic
because yeah that seems like a bad idea
I don't know
he said listen I want to do live just
because it's exciting it makes me
nervous I don't get nervous in my career
anymore right I'm not gonna read it I
try to talk him out of it
[__] you
you know and how would God love him
he he's invested in this Tech
called Proto which is incredible
technology
uh but they they unveiled they unveiled
a new product
and I don't think it was quite ready for
prime time
did you hear his uh pre-show music by
any chance I heard you asking about that
you want me to ask where they got that
no we got it we got it oh you got it I
tested it shout out to our mod blizzard
Woofy for getting it but um
a little silly kind of
a little mischievous right it's like
little it's like a little Home Alone
yeah Luigi's mansion
mansion yeah
[Music]
he's a little wholesome though you know
America's Uncle yeah of course I got
goofed on Plenty by you guys as usual
thank you everybody here's my photo and
you know every time last time I did
Howie's I had a crazy shot
and so here's my new one I guess my legs
you this is this is not edited it's not
there's a close-up on the next Link in
the dark that's [__] that's [__]
that's edited but that is not another
look at the look at the it's got like
artifacts
it's definitely editing it could be
between your legs here let me see yeah
here's the zoom in I just zoomed in so
this is definitely an edit nobody has
legs like that why do you have like the
lowest camel toe of all time yeah well
well I don't know how to tell you this
but between your legs
I do not have a 20 incher so I think
it's just the fold yeah I mean I have
fat boy pants
clearly I think it's time to right it's
just they're in motion I put on some of
one of my pants that I used to wear one
of my shorts I used to like wearing
oh my God cargo so these ones oh my
these ones fit a little better but
they're still pretty wide I guess but
they're better right
um yeah that doesn't look well yeah
actually I don't know they're still
pretty [__] lying holy [__]
yeah that looks that looks yeah but my
leg uh it will flip my legs don't look
like that dude I have normal ass legs so
it's just an angle thing there's no way
that wasn't edited stop it stop [__]
with me that was edited
hey send me the original picture please
that is the original here
show me what how we posted you scam
artists
show me how he's posed
let's see with pizza left please get
smaller shorts for your body yes I know
thank you they're pretty big they're
pretty big
serving 2017 Billy eilish
I think I could jump out of an airplane
and land safely with these parents [__]
you
right here is a post from Howie's
YouTube channel this is on unless dude
how we edited this what the [__] dude it
looks like I'm
I don't be a dick but it looks like I
have cancer or something
what I mean it looks like I'm one day
away from what do you mean by look at my
legs
dude I think it's maybe the wide angle
kind of stretched you a little bit it's
an angle thing because these guys they
have me on and they plot ahead of time
to create the most [__] up angle yes
to screw with me and my body
you've got to eat your skin and bones
also I'm taller than Howie just for the
record
uh I am taller than Highway how are you
rocking my platform Converse a lot
do you guys have seen me next to him I
Tower over Howie Mendel
so anyway uh the show was fun I I love
those guys how he asked me to do
anything I'd say yes you know I mean
he's he's like as I say a National
Treasure although
I um I learned recently maybe I knew
this but forgot he's from Canada
so oh not sure about how I feel about
the National Treasure that's a bummer
huh he's a National Treasure he's saying
he's America's Uncle all this time he's
Canada's Uncle what the [__]
he lives here
and he renounce his Canadian citizenship
man I hope I can text him I'll text him
Howie
can you renounce
live far away oh how he's watching right
now he said I didn't edit or plot that
picture [__]
[__] Howie explain that [__] then
because I don't
it doesn't make sense it's not possible
to have legs that look like that she
look at this also why does it look like
I'm five feet tall foreign
this is not okay I'm not going on this
show again you're standing way behind
them thank you
because he's under five feet tall hey
come on
look at how great they look in the
overalls yeah they're the best they are
the best he is the greatest
you want me to take a picture yeah take
a picture of my legs let's post them on
Twitter
I mean they are pretty I guess pretty
thin but I mean skinny right
skinny ledge
we're taking a photo of my legs hold on
whoa whoa whoa no way okay hold on
I think it was edited actually no [__]
bro yeah we got the original cam dug up
the original oh come on you guys that's
not helpful at all damn bro
are you skipping legs no wonder he was
playing that [__] music okay I know
that one's edited like SpongeBob my legs
are not that thin you got chicken legs
dude he looks like SpongeBob you would
be creeping around the house to this
music I'm SpongeBob where's Ariana here
let's look at the pick I just had all
right Sam we have a new
dude that's edited
how I would have no time to edit that
why is
why is my legs look like that then why
but look how it's all stretched out look
at my feet I have a natural turnout look
at look at how it stretches my feet bro
there's something iffy about this photo
it's the wide angle well so then why you
got to do the stretchy wide part of my
legs
I see if that was the problem
I don't like any of this stuff
we're gonna have to do a leg lineup
where we'll just do our show art
our shins down sure try to pick us out
of a lineup
well anyway
um
there's us
and then uh here was my I guess favorite
part that you might say yeah so how he
brought out the uh and I love you how
I'm sorry I'm sorry you know
uh I can Testify the the real Proto
which we um showcased right before this
because I'll be fair to the product and
show it off
here
uh this this was very nice of this guy
to call in a great comedian I don't
remember his name but Craig
he's the do he did was in Reno 9-1-1
right right wasn't he also in the
Napoleon Dynamite he was his brother
right
maybe yeah very funny guys so he he
called in the heck on me
uh via the magic of Proto so I'm going
to show the good before I show the
disaster to be fair to Howie the
observation so basically what we did is
he he was taken so you know there's just
not you guys like the capital E and
that's that's not the same actor by the
way we ended up with that h3h
Hey Howard can you do me a favor next
time
can you not light it so that like I look
like Uncle Fester
not in makeup you look fine can we get
some front lighting please oh wow I'm
just I'm giving a hard time vain I'm
giving a hard time that's it just being
silly
stop stop it's how uh just bad about the
leg thing so I'll put that h3h okay
interrupt here but that correct then so
so that was the the technology is
amazing he was in a Box live from New
York
terrific technology
I wish I could say the same thing about
it will soon no no soon to be terrific
technology
that's what I'll say about it but right
now I have a uh like a robot in the Box
the Proto box I can't see inside of it
you don't have to see you can listen to
them
do you have a question
sure what do you want to ask is semen
good for for plants okay like we had
said I don't remember oh yes we had said
that uh apparently Harvey Weinstein had
was coming in plants or something and I
had wondered I wonder if that is good
for plants because I've heard urinating
on plants
can offer some unique nutritional is
that a real thing though
urinating on Plants no the the RV
Weinstein apparently it was in
somebody's testimony that like he had
nowhere to bust so he busted in his
plant
right
Lauren sylvan's story about Harvey
Weinstein shooting into a potted plant
there it is
and it said that plant turned into
Jack's magical Beanstalk
mm-hmm
in the soil how does that affect the
plant you can listen listen
[Music]
so I don't think Howie knows much about
like where AI Technology's at plants
he doesn't know about my familiarity
with chat GPT and I didn't have the
heart to tell him is thinking
as an AI hologram
right it does a very thorough response
and the thing is I wasn't sure if he was
[__] with me but he really started to
sweat he was having like a panic attack
is semen bad for plants
you know it's bleeding edge technology
Howie it doesn't always work and I
understand
[Music]
is semen bad for plants yeah and you can
actually get one of these
uh for six thousand dollars they're
available now really yeah I mean having
that powerful technology and a room of
your home yeah I wonder if it's the
question maybe it's it's I don't I
really don't know I don't have personal
preferences or opinions but in general
there is no scientific evidence to
suggest that semen benefits plant growth
we already knew that we knew that there
were no science okay yeah it landed that
one response I don't I don't expect the
AI to do like expensive the traditional
methods of plant care okay okay well
that's an opinion
make a poem about Howie Mandel and Ethan
it's awesome make a poem about Howie
Mandel and Ethan so the owner of this
company Plant his office is here in the
studio and he was right outside freaking
out and I don't think Howie was willing
to move on until at like successfully
undertook a command so it went on for a
really long time
please include coming on a plant how
okay
when can we buy these Howie hello
[Laughter]
I'm telling you this is
this is amazing technology oh yeah
listen to me oh Cutting Edge yes it
works all the way we put a piece of film
on the front so that you can't see it
clear on the camera right you know so
you but Howie it's just one button it's
amazing technology I put a piece of film
on the front so the camera can see it so
it's not blowing out so it's actually
not feeling my finger so maybe can you
take the film off and then it'll blow
out because it's so bright for the
people at home but this is the m you can
have what is your Proto guys I need one
of those and everything he came running
I will get you one watch hi he came
running in at the end
poor guy
hello
it's live I was always thinking Betty
love
I mean this is the mat this is this is
what you get when you go live you know
this is the magic yeah you gotta test
drive that thing a little bit she said
his name she that's it and what more can
you say than that she said it all
she said it all
and that's why I love host of the
popular H3 podcast and one half of the
YouTube channel h3h3 Productions is
known for his witty commentary and
satirical Styles
while delving into various
I like what I'm hearing he's starting to
swear he's stressing for real she likes
you she was all nice that was yeah yeah
thank you Proto wow
that time that they showed windows
my dad's sweating at death but it does
work perfectly they put this stupid are
you stressing about this oh that's so
good a little bit this wasn't ready this
wasn't really a short time it doesn't
matter
what what he's sweating dude
it is it is gold it was the best part in
the comments are gonna be like oh so
horrible the episode today he couldn't
get that machine to work right no this
was everyone's favorite part I know I
can see him glistening you see it's nice
and cool in there trust me she's drowned
out the world
I am here to assist and provide
information based on your inquiries
all right if you have any specific
concerns or preferences regarding our
conversation please let me know and I'll
do my best to assist you accordingly
what's he looking at the uh
named Ethan
Delight
[Music]
he tackles topics with weird shining
bright
his commentary sharp his jokes are Grand
wow Ethan's presence is felt across the
land the problem is she keeps going
Tyler by his side a dynamic duo they
make creating contents
some reaction videos
[Music]
sing
his videos
[Laughter]
okay that's done
I wanted to do something the other day
we talked to you you want to move
you want to move quickly past this or
just can I talk about it
so no now you're talking dad I wanted to
talk about what happened can we talk
about what just happened how we or no
why was this a big why did you want to
do this live was this a big showcase for
you yeah it's a big deal this is a big
deal look can you tell he's sweating
sweating no I saw him I got worried
about him
all right
I felt so bad have you seen when the
microsite the Microsoft does like a
presentation of their new product and
then they get like the blue screen of
death that doesn't matter no it doesn't
anyway the thing
it ended up working that's him running
in it ended up working the the Creator
it's still working it's still working
is this part of the adventure that
you're enjoying
and why are you sweating
talk me through your emotions I'm
curious
you don't understand he has been on edge
about this live going incredibly well
for it is going well from entertainment
I think it's off
thank you it turned up but it ended up
delivering
yeah we're good we're good enough it is
brilliant that's the that's the guy I
built it yeah so yeah okay so anyway I
understand why he came charging in
so from an entertainment perspective I
think the show is really good yeah from
a Proto perspective
this one was was and this is ai ai is
still this is amazing
this one also does what that one that
one does exactly what that one so it
honestly it keeps going and it's all
previous yeah okay
but uh that was fun oh my God that was
funny yeah I love those guys you know
always a pleasure
bad for plants Ah that's a good one Zach
guys let me see if how I responded are
you ready to renounce your Canadian
citizenship no
he didn't uh respond
I guess the answers in the non-answer
wow
pretty Savage he's being rescinded that
should be the Howie Mandel theme song
anytime we talk about him this is the
song he gets I agree I love this for how
he's Vibe so let's see uh also uh to all
the members the beautiful members who
watch see you next Tuesday yesterday
I had another unfortunate situation
uh we have joked about me sharing as a
perk for the five dollar membership my
phone number
and now and now I'm happy to also share
my um
emails
right yeah
yeah also not a joke not a joke here's
what happened and again this is Dan's
fault 100 dance fault because Dan says
[Laughter]
oh [__] this was probably the biggest
one because I just had no idea what was
happening I can't stand that this was
Dan's fault though 100
yeah I have some thoughts on that okay
I'll check my email right now
I'm not going to read it but so the
context is even worse because
xqc's X tweeted me check your email
and although and I'll say this here and
now I'm not getting involved in his
personal life good
you know a girl whatever you went
through you know
uh
uh I'm not the one to talk to be your
voice for that you you know I mean like
anyway it's like I I just wanted to have
a debate with him not like
be the xqc guy right you know but anyway
so a lot of people were like
I was like I'm not going to show you
this email but I'm curious what it is
and of course
kind of [__] up
I'm not going to read it for you guys
but I am curious I'm gonna check it
right now
oh boy
God there's some weird emails in here
foreign
they can see the whole goddamn thing and
everyone's saying stop
I thought they were talking about me
eating the whole time we're texting you
calling you yeah my phone was muted I
got a whole bunch of missed calls yeah
my WhatsApp was blowing up she sent it
too
yep I'm crushing it we resorted to you
because he's scared that yeah and here
you're on your phone and we were all
like why is it not seeing our [__] he's
on his phone
um right what was I doing on my phone
because we were spamming you at this
moment when he was like texting
oh I was in Twitter and xqc was
messaging me yeah
he was
he was kind of
he he was kind of panicked about this
whole thing to be honest
uh with the
exactly with the X yeah
so
well this doesn't show the whole thing
if the next link is the uh because that
one hey Zach
what was going on in the chat uh during
all of this Zach don't you dare play
that for me
hey come on bro stop
it Stan's fall play it when he talks
all right so here it is it chewing oh my
God I'm sorry
wait you guys are all saying stop am I
chewing I'm so sorry
I was losing my mind doing this mind you
the emails are still on screen it's just
edited
[Laughter]
ground yourself
that's what
I blame Dan once again
[Laughter]
once again that's that 100 dance fall
stand by that in fact he [__] up this
is not a good post
this doesn't make any sense and I don't
know why it was posted this subreddit
um so so yeah I showed all the emails
just the beginning of it unfortunately
including
uh his ex but it didn't show anything I
don't luckily I didn't show anything
that was compromising it's funny because
the only reason you didn't open it on
stream the actual email is because you
didn't find it yeah I didn't find it
I saw like Eden's the best or whatever
and I thought it was like a fake name
right it just sounded a little like
silly but that was her if I opened it
bro thank God you would have if you saw
it I saw it I would have you're right
you're right you would have been like
damn this is a crazy email like I wish I
could tell you guys
guys stop posting this stuff it's not
funny even trying to stream without
Cruise help this isn't funny you guys
why are you still posting stuff
that's my money that's my mom trying to
open an email okay it's just not the
same thing right and by the way it's
Dan's fault he sets the streaming setup
for me he goes okay this is foolproof he
says everything will show in this
browser right
I got to defend on this this was like
hold on before you do baby so because
sometimes there'll be two browsers open
if I click a link
and so if the email is open on my right
screen it'll still show that one yeah
yeah even though the browser on my left
screen I'm not a streamer I don't do
twitch right right so that's I'm the
talent I explained it to you though I
explained it to you not good enough
there are two browsers there's Chrome
and Firefox yeah and Firefox oh I'm
sorry
you stop
why'd you stop talking I just following
the rules what happened then just shut
down
what's happening right now does somebody
want to say something
what the [__] just happened
okay I didn't see the button thing oh my
God
so hold on hold on okay all right it's
the button love please
baby you were saying
but Dan was explaining to you before the
button
not right now
anyone else
think what he was trying
okay
he was uh
listen guys it was Dan's fault
that's the only acceptable take on this
tragedy yeah
and Dan I apologize I apologize on Dan's
behalf I apologize to you yeah
go ahead uh this I did that we can move
past the [__] go ahead Dan what were you
saying
all I was saying is yeah Firefox Firefox
is on your computer and I explained to
you that anything that happens in that
just assume it's public
that was that was the ground rule
so that seems like a pretty simple rule
to follow I I don't know I don't know
what to tell you beyond that and so I
mean the show is you have to show stuff
in a browser so you need a browser and
so we've we've quarantined those off
into two separate things to make it real
real nice clear distinction there and he
signed you into different accounts right
so that the problem is I think you
signed in to the main podcast YouTube
slash Gmail that's that's a that was a
recipe for disaster Dan right and so
yesterday that wasn't actually clear to
me I thought you would open your
personal it wasn't until later that
evening that I realized it was the
podcast one which made me less because
then the podcast one is just like a
public one so yeah it was it was nothing
there really wasn't anything too
personal it would have been way more
disastrous if it was like your business
email or whatever you know I don't think
there's even anything there but it's not
your fault but anyway it was funny and
uh you know what I mean this missing
guys your fault I'm doing my best out
here
give me a hug Robin Williams tell me
it's not my fault your fault
thank you your fault all right make up
your mind your fault
um here's the WhatsApp messages
when I was uh yeah I scrolled
Ethan's on screen everything you're
doing bro stop alarms
Ethan your emails on screen Ethan Jesus
Ethan Ethan that's me by the way this is
from my POV here
okay I swear you're trolling I'm not
dude I thought you were at the same time
I'm calling you on your phone number and
on WhatsApp yeah same here we were all
keep saying it's time for the home all
right well it's time for you to be
unemployed then
you better put me on I'll sign a check
in the old folks home you better put my
ass on like steroids and all the [__]
Joe Biden's on sure keep my heart
pressure
conservatorship
so anyway uh shout out to the members
who got that special tease and uh and I
hope that motivates you somehow to
become a member because you just never
know what's going to go down I'll see
you next Tuesday
isn't that true it's very true isn't
that fantastic
moving on
that's true thank you there is uh
something really uh fantastic I want to
share from a fan
as you guys know fan favorite
dark Nathaniel klansman who sometimes
gets a little offensive on his porch
about some of the more tragic moments of
his life
a fan and this guy is amazing mums
mums Young dead
mum's Young dead oh yeah actually so
they posted it on their YouTube channel
which we should definitely uh well let's
watch it there then so they can get the
I read that comment here Mumsy Undead
I'm pretty sure Mumsy Undead I'll tell
you what man
sometimes I sit out here so here's the
YouTube links we can juice them up this
guy is a mega Talent Undead mummy is the
is the channel here I've heard
potentially greatest fan submission ever
yeah because you haven't seen this yet
right only like 10 seconds you watched
like the very beginning of it all right
well let's take a let's take a watch so
this is by Undead mummy and uh we'll put
the link in the description juice it in
the chat oh yeah that's a good idea too
but uh here it is three minutes roll it
take a look
I tell you what man
sometimes I sit out here on the porch
and I get to think
dark thoughts you know sometimes out
here they're nothing to do but think
[Music]
wow you ever sit on the porch and
see the country a lot up by the light
and light sick
make you think about all this by the way
we were wondering what Nathaniel
klansman looks like this is good yeah I
love the concept it's good it's like
Bizarro meat which I like I like that
it's here the God who put us all here
now
someone much darker than that
[Music]
I grew up with my good old friend
Jeremiah
no way that was the close friends real
close
Jeremiah one day he come home he said I
kissed your sister
I wasn't too calm about that because
I'll tell you what man I've been kissing
my sister that's my sister and they
won't gonna be reprogramming with her
Jeremiah that's gonna be me
foreign
out back told him we were going to sleep
some sweet tea
[Music]
Jeremiah
across the line this time Big Brother
I did something I regret I'm not proud
to say it but I put my hands on his neck
wow should the light left his his eyes
the last breath exited his mouth good
insanely called his lifeless body I
realized what I had done but there was
no going back at this point
but I thought if I got to live a good
life here for my sister I got to get rid
of this party this is so good
I took my daddy John Deere
I start digging
and I start digging dude that's amazing
this literally sounds like people
calculations it's like yeah yeah this is
ready for like uh uh best short at the
Academy Awards Nathaniel kleinsman
um so talented I'm sick sweet enough but
I can't take it
was that when I was doing it in front of
the The Language Coach
we should get him to call back in and
I'll do the whole monologue again
I'm just doing them every time I don't
want to put them through that again
and maybe it was maybe it wasn't I was
digging to hide the body maybe I was
digging my own shame trying to hide it
don't have to ever face it again
as I filled in that ditch with my good
friend Jeremiah I said
all right let's go it was gonna be the
same around here
wow
oh wow
Undead but mommy wow blown away I'm
unemployed
a plea for help if anybody out there
I was looking for someone with these
kinds of talents but that I mean and
though the not just the quality but the
speed with which he did that I mean this
didn't happen that long ago this is a
lot of work yeah I was it was probably
what two months ago something like that
maybe a little bit that being said I
will be dmcing this unauthorized use to
my voice just kidding we love you so
much Undead I'm subscribing I'm loving
you I'm gonna comment I love Undead
Mommy
oh you know what we need we need a bees
from space X Undead mummy collab win
the two greats
yeah huge thank you to you man that was
beautiful I absolutely loved that
that could be potentially I've been
thinking if we could do H3 on Broadway
and I do wonder if Nathaniel klansman
could be a compelling
stage character what do you think Olivia
oh my God for like a one-man play uh no
there'd be there'd be another Ensemble
yeah it would be a whole ensemble a
variety show of sorts a musical break
into some song and dance at certain
points you never know you know a little
banjo wow what a beautiful B plot
happening somewhere in America
little banjo music play as this raffle
down river
seeing me and I see me a child with a
strange looking eye
staring me down as a float past the
dealt
I heard I thought I heard the delta
blues come from that old banjo but it
was something else
something a little
a little different little stranger
yeah
it's a map and I was coming down that
stream and hit me a rock
you know
lots of rocks in the river but this one
was especially sharp and brutal
um
took a nice chunk out my raft had to
Ford the side of the river there take
breath
to go my boat
my good friend
jezeiah
we said dang dang God I ain't know what
we gonna do next here with this River
broken
then out from the bush as we heard a
little rustling behind us said oh maybe
some good old boys out here to help us
with our raft
they'll turn around seen me a big boy
and a overalls
shotgun
saw it off real vicious
pointed right at me he said what you
doing around here boy
I said Who you calling boy man
I just looking for some help here with
this here raft you got any kind of
Gorilla Tape or none of that
[Music]
he said why don't you step on over here
and squeal for me piggy
he said squeal Piggy
eyes confused first I didn't know what
was about happened
they went up the genocide they hog tie
that boy
you know wrist to wrist ankle to ankle
[Music]
meanwhile they took me out by the tree
Yonder
not easy talk about what happened there
behind the tree but they put that
shotgun right up to me sawed off and
everything and they said squeal Piggy
I said I know what you mean Square they
says you know what a pig sound make that
sound in
I start to squeeze you I'm just doing
the plot of Deliverance I don't know if
you guys have seen that
[Music]
it gets a little [__] up from that
point but yeah you know where it's
probably yeah it's just the plot of
Deliverance good movie
the universe the dark the Daniel
Universe yeah
[Applause]
Jeremiah
and pueblas you should just switch the
consonant every time
that's my family we the diets the
ezidias All Right Moving On
we haven't talked about much anything
here let's talk about we have more Goofs
than gasps but we should probably talk
about something right xqc there's a lot
to talk about unpacked there
yeah there is uh we're only 43 minutes
in
okay Ethan
all right so let's let's debrief and we
can come back and look at this stuff uh
okay
so as you guys probably saw
the xqc conversation
I wasn't sure how many people were going
to be interested in that
and like I said uh on Monday
we had thought about canceling it in
fact everybody wanted me to cancel it
yeah I was not really feeling it well
and neither were you I mean you were
asking like what what you thought what
we thought we should do and I was like
yeah I don't know but glad it it went
pretty well so I'm glad we did my
concern and I think you guys shared it
was just that it's kind of like a
there's there's no way to win this
because he's so messy and so so lame
such a douche which it did play out
pretty much the way I anticipated but
what I didn't anticipate is that he
would get so thrown off that he would
start writhing around on the ground
which was awesome that's a that Meme
will live forever that was content right
there well and actually the greatest
meme that's come out of it some of you
might not have seen because it took
place on Twitter yesterday
or right yesterday early in the morning
as he continued to harass me in my
direct messages after the debate
um but you know yeah I was prepping at
night and I was looking at all my notes
and thinking like is this gonna work and
then when I heard back from Vince
vintage vents
I knew that I had something concrete
good to hit him with right because then
it's no longer a hypothetical there's
like an actual person there so that's
why I said let's do it you know and well
we did do it here's some of the in the
aftermath of that
here's the DMS that took place now a lot
of people I was reading was like why did
xqc agree to do this and I wanted to
make it clear not only did he agree to
do this he's the one that he proposed it
he proposed it
I wasn't even thinking about debating
xqc he said debate me old guy I was like
sure
you're dumb ass enough to come here and
fit into the you know the usual suspects
on that
so here is 11 P.M Monday night
he's obviously seething and coping hard
I don't know the reception on the on the
internet seemed to be universally people
always find a reason to hate me or say
I'm annoying like I saw this comment
they're like if you didn't think xqc
lost you're an idiot and if you didn't
think Ethan was annoying you're annoying
too
better annoying than a loser
but you know there's always the edgy
kids but for the most part I think that
it was a unanimous uh goofing on xqc am
I right for sure yeah yeah
so here's the unsolicited hate DM I got
and my policy on this stuff and I've
talked about this before if I get
unsolicited hate mail or DMS that shit's
public boy I'd not ask you to message me
this is not part of a private
conversation this is like you coming uh
to my house and leaving like a [__]
mean letter on my doorstep I didn't
invite you showed my goddamn private DMS
oh yeah poor game so he said you know
the whole point of the show is that you
actually discuss points kicking me out
and doing Echo chamber tweets about the
stuff you didn't prep for is soy
Behavior man it was when I read soy
Behavior I was like I'm post I'm posting
this [__]
I'm gonna understand like
he's so delusional he thinks that he was
the one discussing points
and I was the one
deflecting it's like a total uh
perversion of reality
uh but uh okay
I don't think I I just said k
again you know I saw this at 1 50 a.m
hit him with the case I mean because I
was like okay bro listen listen let's
you know whatever bro yeah we did it
it's done there's no more to talk we
already talked about it yeah why you
coming to talk to me about I said K and
then he says go back to bed old guy
I was like all right
said bro you haven't slept in two days
you probably would have performed better
with a nap beforehand
just saying it's fair
he said
if it was about actual truth I would
have just spammed the group chat full of
files and made it boring gray hair Andy
and when I saw him say gray hair Andy I
was like
this man
I'm like nobody's this this isn't twitch
chat old man this is an almost 30 year
old man I'm like yeah I'm 38. I have
gray hair I have two and soon to be
three kids you know what I mean like the
whole gray hair Andy thing doesn't
it's not registering is that like it was
meant to be like an actual insult to me
uh love everything and they just add
Andy to everything yeah it's just yeah
it's probably that's how he talks to his
like grandparents
probably what's up gray hair Andy
well you're not even that much older
than him at Stone pointed out he's 30.
yeah
not that significant anyways no not not
not not that significant I agree you
know
um hey Grandma
take these these pancakes suck
white hair candy right way here Auntie
[__]
yeah I mean dude this is like you know
can drop the act man it's just me and
you you don't have to lie to kick it bro
okay and then and then he drops this
graph I guess because he says if I cared
about truth I would have showed this
compelling evidence this is what he
showed me here
um
here's the I posted I just said what
this was it so he would have brought
this crazy ass
uh wait is that not cropped that's what
he sent me this is literally the photo
he sent me Checkmate not this this is
cropped yeah but this is what he sent me
right he cropped it you you didn't well
he took it on his phone or some I don't
know what the [__] this is like the most
concerning thing because this like what
is he thinking here this is just focused
dude
I said dude you're coping my friend
again it's 1 50 a.m I'm in bed I'm
watching One Piece my kids are sleeping
my dogs are with my beautiful wife is
sitting next to me in my in my
California king-sized bed
you know
in my air-conditioned room
and uh I'm have I'm chilling you know I
mean 50 plus unbiased sample size coping
on this dick he said
once again
you don't probably should have kept that
to yourself my guy you don't have to lie
to kick it bro it's just me and you
right now
you had one graph that proved me right
all right bro listen we already had this
conversation whoa I don't care anymore
he's trying to rehash this [__] you can
tell he's coping so hard my guy
uh continues he continues
also the YouTube [__] is literal cut
down for VOD frogs
this was like 10 minutes later I thought
it was done frogs does it like this is
more yeah like he's like so maladjusted
like
does he like think that everybody talks
like this like what the [__] does that
mean it's a pretty common twitch thing
but yeah it's weird to talk to an
untwitched person like that but also
like it doesn't even make sense because
he's like oh it's just for people that
want to watch the VOD you're still
stealing [__] content he's going back
to the beginning of the conversation
it's like dude I'm not a mindset of like
dming sure yeah somebody I am not
rehashing this with you now bro I don't
care he's like yeah I posted on YouTube
so people can see it so yeah yeah that's
the issue the [__] VOD frogs
okay bro stop you if you wanted to have
I'm gonna have a new role with xqc if he
wants to have a conversation with me he
needs to like
chill out on the twitchbonics
I need I need English APL yeah
so anyway this was like 10 minutes later
was it when's the last message I got it
was 1 54 a.m this one came at
209 a.m so oh I didn't even realize this
was in the middle of the night that
makes it so great that's what I'm saying
I'm chilling in bed with my wife my
daughter I thought it was like in the
early to mid evening no no 2 A.M a.m
texting wow yeah fucking's one of my
favorite nights so I thought it was over
I said oh there's more okay
says no one cares about the cross
analytics stuff because they have no
impact it's like tell it to the judge
bro
tell to somebody who gives a [__] his
niche as [__] he says I give 100 the
revenue if I had to it's not meant to
make money lol okay
is he really trying to convince me like
he wants to convince me that I'm wrong
and I said ironically which I don't know
if he picked up on said right because
why would you care about YouTuber
revenue of 100K when kick just paid you
100 million he said exactly
I said right
right he says I don't care about it it
pays the editors and [__] like
immediately a hundred thousand dollars
[Music]
and then he goes I don't know why you're
so caught up with money [__] you got
[__] money can't buy like why I was like
[__] what the [__] are you talking
about
you message me at 2AM and you start
talking about VOD frogs and and revenue
share what do you I didn't I didn't
start this conversation
so he goes why are you so caught up with
money
I said it matters to people whose videos
you use I mean hundred thousand dollars
not chump change to most people on this
earth right
including me frankly that's a lot of
money I mean Jesus Christ
you know uh and I said I meant to say
after that not everyone is a millionaire
and at the same time he said like I
stated We Care a [__] ton if we want if
they want something from us we will give
them a flat fee would be fine too again
completely missing the point of the
whole conversation we had
so exhausting
that's why we try to be careful to a
certain degree sometimes mishaps happen
but we're on top of it I said it's not
your decision to make bro
then I will continue to expand my
library of react friendly uh channels
and react potential and keep doing it
while you search for victims that don't
exist okay Ethan
again
paid actor uh
vintage Vincent is it vintage Vince
Vince vintage yeah Vince vintage great
guy great videos
uh he says the world doesn't need your
help
I'm like dope dude it's 2 30 a.m I did
not start this conversation
I said you asked me to debate the issue
dude I'm not looking to save the world I
just wanted to have a conversation about
fair use with you which we did
he's like a rage dming me at 2 30 a.m
saying the world doesn't need you bro
I'm like okay
I didn't say it nobody said that man
you know who needs me my [__] wife
and kids dude it's 2 30 a.m leave me the
[__] alone
okay gotcha stay safe wish you nothing
but the best I said okay same thanks to
you
and then that is something we'll say
about XTC is as evidenced by his uh
on-again off-agan relationship with his
son doesn't seem like a guy to hold a
grudge past like nah 30 seconds dude I
at some point in the debate
um love and I looked at each other
because
said something like pretty it was like a
tiny bit maybe over the line I think you
were like
I'm way more entertaining than you
you're not even entertaining and then
you were like I'm gonna walk that back
I'm just being very talented and he like
cracked a smirk and he was like oh thank
you man I Do by the way he is talented I
agree yeah this twitch thing where no
one holds grudges and they basically
like when everyone has a meltdown
everyone's mad at each other one week
later everyone's fine just all good
awesome okay I guess the YouTube world
is not as small as the twitch right I
guess everybody's got to be friends
there yeah you don't know I don't know
it's a foreign world to me I'm just a
frog Andy gray-haired guy
oh bald I'm bald old froggy frog boy and
bestie so but anyway when he found out
that I was posting all these I was
posting them in real time and I assumed
he was seeing them it was literally I've
got a message I would post it
and so I I assumed frankly that he was
seeing it but he comes back to me let's
see this this ended at 3am
oh no sorry this ended at 2 30 A.M
then I got another one from him at 3 40
A.M
I don't know why I was still up
I guess one piece
um
wait where's the beginning of this the
beginning
if you scroll down
oh okay yeah
where
huh below going up you're going up you
got to go down this is just to show the
first yeah that's just showing the first
tweet oh okay so he said something like
yo dude what the [__] he there was there
was personal information so I decided I
did poster frankly and I I regretted it
I was like ah it's nobody's business it
was stuff about his ex and I
I didn't think it was I didn't I
regretted doing that and
and uh I was up to that point it was him
like arguing and attacking you yeah and
then suddenly there's the third party
involved and yeah and I said you know
what I erased and I I even apologized
I'm sorry I I posted those so I
excluding those he's like yo what the
[__] why are you posting the dams and
then he's really angry now he says I
know it kills you inside you lost so
much time and money in that lawsuit
I said buddy which one you got to be
more specific
says I don't know whichever one really
you seem so bitter after it I said I'm
fine
troll dancers not looking to engage much
with this
this is when the real [__] juice
comes he says anyway when the bills kick
in and you're struggling remind yourself
you leaked DMS out of insecurity and
then
he hits me with this hmm don't forget I
got your whole house on my wrist
kissy lips
and I was just like bro you are [__]
out of your mind I love that you just
hit him with the smiley I was like this
is so crazy I was
out because I was just like I want to
inspect this first of all the watch I'm
pretty sure is at like 8 P.M or
something so it I don't think he took it
then and also he's sitting on the floor
with his little feet together right
right he's sitting on the carpet and his
empty Loveless literally nobody's there
except you're maid who you pretend
doesn't exist because you're you have no
social skills you call people frogs
you could practice your social skills
with your maid that's a good place to
start
you can't even do that I'm talking of
course about this
this clip was going viral before our
conversation of him
this is embarrassing man I mean really
it is he's sitting here uh streaming and
there's actually takes two cleaning
women to clean his disaster of a [__]
room just living in filth and he's so
embarrassed watch this he he starts
typing
secret messages to chat
because he's so embarrassed normally I'm
not like
embarrassed chat so like I'm more social
and
chill
but this time
there it's
a lot of [__] trash
holy [__]
I'm like actually shy
sorry
bruh
they've been cleaning for years I don't
even know what to say
she's looking to look at her looking at
his dumb ass oh she's like bro you're a
weird dude like a weirdo Bro Look at
that side a
[__] while carrying she's like I can
read you know
I speak English and I can read
[__] I'm sentient you know throughout
the night now
oh cool let's get back to this police
shooting video whatever the [__] is
watching you're a weirdo bro
that's so perfect so clearly very
dysfunctional I mean my God just get up
man say you know I'm so sorry for the
mess you know
apparently though if they filled up like
two whole trash bags of [__]
anyway so here is the uh I was actually
curious how much this watch cost because
he says it's worth the more than my
whole house
and I think it was like between 250 and
400 000. it was like 400 000. yeah which
don't get me wrong
it's an expensive watch
obviously yeah
but uh I don't think he knows anything
about me I don't think you can even own
a house in La for four hundred thousand
dollars frankly no not that it really
matters not that it it doesn't no but I
mean with the housing market how it is
400k I don't think that gets you
anything no down payment maybe the guest
bathroom on his wrist that's right
that's the pool house yeah
but I didn't even respond because I was
like whatever bro you know what I mean
yeah you're worth more your watch is
worth more than me
uh there's and since this is this tweet
has gone pretty pretty viral I've seen
tons of people naming it
I've got a whole album of memes
let me see how many
likes it's gotten
watch it people were really loving it
though
oh a perfect too
uh 92 000 likes 6 000 retweets
I think this meme's gonna live for a
long time
and then uh Vince vintage
actually reached out to xqc after the
podcast he said yo tell him to reach out
I'll give him 10x
here's the message he sent him what's up
xqc this is uh Vince vintage from
yesterday I wanted to follow up on your
offer to compensate the creators
crickets
he's quick to respond to me boy I bet if
I message him right now I was like yo I
heard from your ex instant response in
fact I'll test it right now should I
but Vince vintage nothing
should I do that I kind of want to do
that experiment is that [__] up or is
that funny no not like what would you
follow it up with no I just say it never
mind correct you mistake
no what if I just said hi uh who cares
he wouldn't respond to me we all know he
would I but this was sent like you know
two days ago now
he quote tweeted
yeah he said hey excuse he put up this
cryptic like uh
crybaby Tweet now imagine that every day
for years you made to believe that
everything you lived was a lie and that
it's your fault somehow someone is
living in a fantasy
okay dude
okay dude yeah I mean [__] so he quote
to it and said now imagine that someone
said to hit them up to get paid on the
content they stole
exactly retweet likes we're all here for
you bincy boy vincey baby
I'm searching for victims that don't
exist though
you know
so here's an album of all the memes and
this stuff is fantastic
you guys will love these
uh our subred first started out don't
forget I got your whole house on my
wrist this looks like some spaghetti and
peas and corn nice
spaghetti peas and corn I got your whole
and of course the watch was just a
hideous
like a Rube Goldman freak squash
I mean you're gonna watch connoisseur
Zach I asked you about it
um yeah I guess just it's a very
expensive watch and all those diamonds
are Factory so I'll give it that but I
wouldn't buy that I think it's hideous
you do I don't think the Riso I don't I
really don't think it's gonna hold its
value
in the the long term there it is so nice
investment dummy do you think you can
even tell the time on it no you he
absolutely cannot wait hold on let me
pull up the the watch again so that's a
that's an uh AP skeleton
um Audemars piguet skeleton with a
frosted uh I believe white gold band and
then rainbow diamonds around the bezel I
have a hard time reading that so
so how oh yeah I mean are these
yeah cool Raj bro hey what time is it by
the way how about that I it's what time
is it xqc it just seems like just like
kind of like a [__] you watch to buy
like there's no sentimental anything
that's how he used it yeah
uh xuc responds to Ethan B like this was
my favorite Zach
that was literally so so funny
oh is this it and we got the the listing
here it is
I believe this is it it was linked in an
article okay
price on request like AP they make a
great watch but this is just ugh
what time is it
oh my God is it like Pride Edition
right kind of is isn't it that is kind
of dope how with like these are natural
colored gems I'm assuming are they like
Sapphire that's very cool how they do
that no it's all Factory which I love
about it because a lot of places do it
aftermarket hell no yeah not AP no but
it without all the [__] on it it would
be a really nice watch
at the exact one X has yes looks like an
ally
okay I don't think he I think he is
probably I don't think he I think he's
like let me get the most [__]
expensive watch I can buy and it just so
happened to be rainbow right all right
maybe okay Ethan the Arthur angry meme
with the watch fantastic we love that
and don't forget I got your whole house
on my wrist this man has a house on his
wrist which is actually more accurate
frankly right
then um good
then what he said don't forget I got
your whole house on my wrist 2 30 at
least this one tells the time
don't forget I got your whole house on
my wrist of fried egg
all right they don't know my wrist costs
more
than their houses that's very very very
true probably too his daily life
definitely this is him at any party yeah
this was from Linus Tech tips getting in
on the fun damn shout out uh don't
forget I got your whole house on my
wrist that's funny
that is a flex how much you think that
video card costs
cup okay that's what I'm saying
now you want to press me
uh and don't forget I got the whole
ocean on my wrist
that's bring out the whole ocean
uh and don't forget I got your whole
house on my wrist Ben Beale I've never
seen this this is impressive for him
that's fire that's very impressive
Flames this is this is him
don't forget I got your whole house on
my wrist that's Heat
like Shrek
thank you
uh
tamaguchi don't forget I got your haul
agachi tamaguchi that's the luxury
version the gooch
don't forget I got your house on my
wrist
uh cameras he literally has oh yeah a
whole house on his wrist unfortunately
he's unable to move because it's a house
is that a camera original yeah the rest
are yeah these are these are cam joints
from this point don't forget I got your
whole house on my wrist okay
you think he's got god cards Dude oh no
doubt yeah
those can't be his real fingers right
dude look at his neck no wonder he was
doing the [__] worm on the ground
he's looking very wrong dude he's very
worm-like yeah wow
uh uh here he says I have a whole house
on my wrist it's in my wrist in my wrist
it turns out his his wrist has literally
been replaced with the house how serious
that is your house oh this is literally
my house fantastic very accurate
statement in that case
this is uh sorry I went a little off the
rails this morning
Zach you'd probably prefer this one
right yeah that's hype as [__] yeah this
one's actually Swiss made apparently
yeah Swiss made McDonald's watch Ronald
McDonald [__] dude you think so oh [__]
his kids I wouldn't say that does it but
you know shout out you know if the
apologies McDonald's I retract that if
the Hamburglar was on there it might be
a little better
what the [__] even mortgage Aaron loans
in on this whoever you guys are don't
forget I got your whole house on my
wrist baby
this is a real company
apparently yes it seems like it they
have 16 followers I don't know how real
that is which one how did you even find
this which one of you owns this company
nice drive more Aaron Morgan who's got
Stakes
that's a whole Cuckoo's Nest that's a
cab original for sure yeah everything
since the Wizard of Oz one Pepe the pig
love that
happy whipping
okay
Peppa it's my boy Pepe here he has uh
nothing
he's got his whole wrist on his wrist I
got my wrist on my wrist
really good job cleaning that up fam wow
literally my wrist oh you're rich
[Applause]
don't forget I got your whole house on
my Piggly wigglies ah that is not my
foot
you sure yep and here is my beautiful
home and not that I want to flex it but
it is a public matter since I
I basically talked about it when I made
that mudahar video so long ago so people
know where I live in my house and that's
fine
but here he is don't forget I got my
wrist on your whole house wow
stalking on you dude we Galactus so
there it is there it is
people are having fun with it
what is this one a work of art another
one
here is xqc little pump is currently
residing on xqc's wrist okay
this is I guess miniature us I think
that just mean
I think that's really nice beautiful I
don't know what what does that do a
little pup
no idea alrighty
shout out to the fam
shout out to um
there's this subreddit
xqc cow I don't know if it's like a
snark or subreddit or a fancy that was
his username before oh it's oow
OverWatch
xqc-o-w OverWatch oh but it sounds like
they're calling him a cow like a low cow
that's not so is that a Sno because I
went there uh the past few days and it's
all snark Rod no that's it so it's a fan
sub
well I think it seems like most
subreddits you can never really tell
right do they hate you dude
but there were some good memes over
there shout out to the execute sea cow
folks over there
love that
but uh
okay this is where you know the world is
really [__] you guys and this is a
trigger warning oh
both keemstar and
Tristan Tate
have reportedly handed me the dub
keemstar says Ethan one
thank you keemstar
uh bestie material uh and and H3 owned
executive says Tristan Tate
which I think you have bigger problems
to deal with yeah why are you watching
which don't watch that don't watch my
show yes you have bigger [__] to deal
with be prepping prepping for court yeah
uh there was a really funny comment I
think somebody pointed out it's just
because I'm not fat anymore here look at
this I'm not even kidding when I say I
think most of Ethan's haters literally
just hate him because he was fat now
he's losing weight and they're able to
at least concede that he's good at some
things
that's crazy that's not a bad Theory and
it's uh generally there's something
there
you know
truly
so shout out to my besties
keemstar and Tristan Tate
who despite their hatred of me still
gave me the dub
Vincent uh Vince vintage of course
changed his
um
his bio to paid actor
I'm a paid actor which he was a he was
accused of being by accident she was
yeah we paid him a lot of money it's
still one of the more baffling
uh responses to a point I brought up
I was when I went back and was watching
bits of the debate I was really
flabbergasted when he said that
I was watching his kick chat at the time
and uh as soon as you started reading it
their whole chat started spamming paid
actors so I think you just saw that and
for sure every time
um
he was on Kick when we were doing that
yeah oh he wasn't on Twitch no no so
many people watch him on Kik 50. 50
000 yeah yeah wow a lot of people went
over there for him who who are his fans
like genuinely if he did a meet-up who
would be there
probably 16 to 23 19 23 year old man
yeah Gamers OverWatch Gamers unite
juicers is he a good gamer is he good at
games
well he was Pro in OverWatch with the
least skill
uh character people don't watch him
because he's good at video games not
anymore no definitely not
Vince vintage shout out to my boy paid
actor what did he mean in OverWatch
Winston
he was a Winston man yeah
dork he was the best Winston in the
world sure everyone roasts I'm sure I'm
sure he was good that's how he blew up
wasn't it from playing that yeah yeah
Winston man
well he the fact that he was reading
chat during the conversation is a fat L
first of all right and it's like dude be
consistent do you want me to be serious
or silly or do you want to I bring up a
really valid point that I would love
your answer to and then you say paid
actor okay
of course people love that uh Ela came
into curb stomp uh
oh this isn't this but this is funny
everything
I can't believe he did that
at a certain point
[Music]
at a certain point when you're
is that gonna get oh no that one's safe
I checked it as well thank you Zach
you're the man
yeah I mean if your debate opponent
starts doing the worm then I think
they've conceded
watch out for that that'll be in my
debating handbook one day right watch
for your opponent to go on the ground
and start writhing that will mean you
won
yeah
but where's the ELA Alpha edit it might
be that this one has the wrong Link in
it oh xqc update number four
here is the is the one we just watched
yep
H3 versus xqc debate in a nutshell
this guy over here is cooked
oh my God how cooked can you be dude
this guy is flame broiled he is done
cooked
good application I forgot about that
stuff those being out there
here's the ELA uh Alpha moment thank you
guys Ethan you want to talk about
amounts of transformation then if we
want to move on to that topic let's just
get some of your uh your I think your
wife's old merch right which is like oh
yes
I saw that oh I've seen it okay so you
can still sometimes when somebody gets
confused at the company when one of the
Sweatshop guys gets it wrong never gets
the wrong one oh no we're we are
thieving I actually wasn't planning to
come in but you brought up that in fresh
listen then talk to me because I'm the
person running 35 yeah you wanna talk
about it talk to me
yeah that was pretty baller I love that
she did that because frankly and he got
kind of pissy too he was like oh bring
everyone in it's like well basically
talking about her company she got every
right to come defend herself yeah
also at the end a little misogynistic I
think Ela mentioned that but when I went
back and watched I felt that too yes he
was very don't interrupt me yeah
I was like dude
maybe you wouldn't be single he's like
I'm talking to him if you had a little
respect for the ladies
you wouldn't be getting divorced
frankly and listen he made he went after
my marriage and the man is going through
a divorce I mean you know what I mean I
mean what the [__]
no you actually in this case
none of the best I know you the best
know you
uh there's so many good ones xqc worm in
the wild
here it is he's a worm in the wild
streamer XC and live action adaptation
of grounded that looks true here it is
one more time
yeah wow I believe him he's killing his
majesty he's doing great you did great
sweetie
Ethan's list is getting too long I guess
it uh
again I don't I don't like the whole tap
dancing uh thing because listen we're
gonna we're gonna have a debate someday
where
it's not gonna go like
like gonna go like this you know I just
got to prepare myself sure was that the
worm you were so sorry is that the worm
you were expecting him to do by the way
because I was expecting him to do like
the dance move I was not expecting me to
do that yeah that was very simple I have
a friend who used to do that so it kind
of was what I was really I think the
worms I had never seen that yeah I've
never seen that but it's not the most
flattering image to a third person it
was an interesting go-to because
yesterday on see you next Tuesday
everyone's trying to get me the work do
the worm I was like hell no I'm not
putting that out there
you're not recording that
oh what the [__] Roma Army
2 300 Canadian with no message
but what do I owe this uh tremendous
Army thank you
generous very kind
imager album of all the heck of it wait
already I already did this one right
Zach
oh no these are different ones it's a
different one oh my God xqc is just
getting cooked man
oh when Ela came in yeah
love that we'll be right back this
really should go in rotation
it's in this is fantastic
here's my face hiding I didn't even see
that I'm in I'm in your closet Felix
yeah I updated the button screen
yesterday
yeah good new ones in there so good
should say something crazy so we can
show them off today
I know we have enough button today man
when you're losing a debate to Ethan and
it says all relatable we're all reliable
excuse me and it's that one Teddy fresh
shirt that looked like another
pretty much
got him I hope people keep bringing that
up you know
it gives me frankly an opportunity to
talk about Teddy fresh to a big audience
right
very good promotion I think true this is
always a killer from The Simpsons uh I
sleep in a race car do you because
Milhouse's dad after getting divorced
Homer says I sleep in a big bed with my
wife still
so good arguably my favorite Simpsons
joke of all time so [__] this was
during the golden age right yeah it was
like 10 years Peak Peak
Simpsons you guys should go back and
watch the first 10 seasons they are
some of the best TV it really is yeah so
[__] good
uh here I am tending to my garden wait
what's that uh it's a little wormy
oh that's cute thank you wormy um early
bird they help keep the soil healthy
Ela walks on screen I run Teddy fresh
talk to me my four-year-old would love
that giraffe I'm having a third kid with
him
oh God what is this POV you tried to
explain the recent pod to a non-viewer
bro I'm telling you xqc had zero
argument he just came on the a Street
podcast used measurements with his hands
spoke gibberish called someone he he
content stole from a paid actor and then
oh my God Ila came out with big boss
girl energy and it's like I'm the face
of Teddy fresh not Ethan talk to me and
I [__] you not he became a worm bro
[Laughter]
he's awesome
this is such a phenomenal photo
so good
the body language is so weird
oh God
there it is
oh and then here's kind of like
he's on his like L tour so immediately
after this he went to Vegas which is of
course the perfect place to go when
you're down and out and have a gambling
addiction
yeah
blow off some steam blow off some steam
here's the post where he announces it
let's see
xq LOL cow I think that should be his
new name
nobody suggested that yet no you so
original one
he says moving to Vegas when I wake up
I was confused by this he wasn't talking
about like moving there was he
I think he is
because he came back five hours later he
says I'm not cut out for this and then
came back oh no this is just a joke
[__] is going on with this guy he says
this isn't the ending I hope for when I
got to Texas
well nobody saw the worm coming
should be a lot of fun tonight it sucks
to leave so much behind but I have
mentally moved on from all this actually
better days ahead it sounds like he's
moving to Vegas
yeah so here so here he is like uh two
hours later
sitting with Aiden Ross and losing
probably tens of thousands of dollars at
the uh blackjack table well when he uh
when you did the the call with him he
said he hadn't slept in two days yeah so
he's probably hasn't slept since I mean
by three here his body is literally
shutting down so I mean like is it
possible to be that wired without drugs
and I'm not accusing him of anything I'm
literally just wondering because I
personally have never known somebody to
not sleep for three days with that were
like I guess in some really where rare
sleeping disorders but to not sleep for
three days is really really really
extreme
problem slept right you think he does
like Adderall or something oh no I was
just saying he probably slept between
what it's like a two-hour flight he I
was watching he literally went from the
debate to the blackjack table with Aaron
Ross no kiss
yeah yeah
yeah made it here he is
God they must be spending a lot if
they're letting him film at the table
because I know they have strict rules
about that
hmm
really strict rules
so they must know his he's such a mark
dude probably a private table yeah
definitely at the high rollers
they see his watch and they're like the
Mark has arrived
here you go Mr Felix wherever you like
here he is balling gonna just
gonna be just winging it and living life
for two to three days good man
fun
serving c word is this watch more than
worth more than my whole house
can you zoom in a little more maybe I
can't that's right this car if I had a
guess wait wait Zoom back in real quick
hold on let me see if I can do more here
is that helpful uh what is that that's
not Factory that's some dog [__] loser
idiot yeah
I hate when people do that man
dude he's doing the Zach Lewis pose
though he's learning from the best here
man good job Felix he's a better watch
He's flexing
get a better watch idiot
here he is uh who the [__] am I kidding
I'm going home this life isn't for me
five hours later probably after losing
like two hundred thousand dollars
Mega shout out to Aiden for setting me
up though from one Mark to another
dude this is so illegal
taking pictures you can almost see the
cards w just kidding again up 180. okay
sure 180 dollars uh yeah awesome
probably
W
um
but here they are talking about me
actually uh what's your name circle
jerking about uh what a douche I am
check it out right okay
that's Ray that's Jordan you guys may
have my old house yeah I remember this
guy yeah yeah yeah yeah gotta imagine
the amount of money you have to lose for
them to put you up like this
basically it's all crew you guys are
gonna go down there I'm gonna come with
you
these guys live like rock stars because
of one reason
a shady [__] crypto casino this is
the only reason that these guys live so
fat and so large they have done nothing
like in terms of like business sense in
terms of like personal accomplishes in
terms of like putting in hard work to
develop something where it pays off
don't get me wrong they'd be doing well
but this level of high living is
literally because steak a shady [__]
crypto casino is paying them ungodly
amounts of money yeah their existence is
an advertisement for them and and
they're they're they you know they
trounce around like uh their big [__]
but you guys are just sellouts That's it
man
subsidized straight up sell out Behavior
by both of you [__] losers hear us on
yeah
and we're gonna give you bread guess
what bro if I in an alternate universe
where I sold out to steak I could yeah I
could get paid fat too I was gonna say
every any streamer on Twitch could be
them dude Fouseytube no offense just got
to deal with kick right literally right
as this [__] started coming up kick was
like let's pay him now is the time to
strike
yeah so [__] a song no no a song I
thought you would sing us a song he
didn't even say Hassan that's the funny
part he's like so obsessed look at this
[__] so [__] a song yeah yeah no no a
song I thought he was a sing us a song I
love a [__] song and H3 Flex on it
Flex on Flex in the camera no bro no bro
that's why [__]
uh I think it was charging nothing
he leaked the DMs I I didn't like that
is it it's five DMs like yeah that was
but that was so cool that you you Flex
on them
oh my God let me back that up for you
you guys know this is being filmed right
these guys are so embarrassed I love
this he leaked my DMs shut the [__] up
[__] can I care about your DMs I don't
owe you anything Aiden Ross is like
every kid that I knew that went to like
Hebrew school and I'm not trying to be
anti-semitician because I'm just saying
how it is did you go to the Hebrew
school with a bunch of rich kids well no
no no not not that it's just their
mentality the way they talk the way they
act that was so sick dude how you flexed
on him like it's just it's it's certain
like
I've said this about Aiden so many times
but he continues to give off this energy
that was so cool Gaston that was so cool
xqc how you did that in the DMs
brother hey hey Aiden you sniff any
chairs lately brother
Aiden you sniff xqc's chair when he got
up to go to the bathroom
[__] little freak charge
brother Aiden what does it mean
he leaked the DMs I I didn't like that
is it it's by the DMs like
this whole mentality is so silly to me
we're not it wasn't a private
conversation you literally just messaged
me rude [__]
yeah that was but that was so cool
that was so cool Gaston it's like every
kid I've played basketball with
I just that's the how I'm mentally
depicting well and what's crazy is that
xqc accepts the compliment he's like
yeah I know it wasn't sure it wasn't it
he's getting clowned on by like the
whole internet
okay sure I'll take the credit he's
taking the credit for that fire
but the joke is is that I know how much
his ass is worth then it's a big house
the watch is not worth his house that
was the whole [__] point this guy is
the hottest [__] loser ever that was
the hope there is zero percent chance he
knew that he was he was obviously super
angry he was rage posting they came one
after the other after the the but the
dots were moving now all of a sudden it
was a joke
I'm pissed off so I'm gonna send you a
photo of a watch I know isn't worth your
house to own you and send you kisses say
it is he dude you're so true why would
you even try to make that argument why
are you saying like what's the joke what
am I missing let's say it's true so so
what's the joke where's the OWN
the joke is that it doesn't make sense
just like his whole uh debate bro you
just don't understand xqc humor man yeah
dude you're not a frog you're not a
YouTube frog you're not a bad frog man
you wouldn't get it you're like you're
an old Andy you're you're a gray hair
Andy frog you're you're an old Andrew or
whatever
an old Andrew by the way how old is
Aiden Ross
uh he's like 23. yeah I'm 21. this is
[__] you it's like you wanted to older
than me so 30 year old xqc is hanging
out with like 20 year old Aiden Ross to
get to get him to be like you're so cool
dude
okay sure I'll take the credit but the
joke is is that I know how much his ass
is worth then it's a big house the watch
is not worth his house that was the
whole [__] point but still explain
that joke please I need to hear Aiden's
response to that hold on right right
because I know Aiden's not following
there's no shot even listen no no no no
no
I was like yeah that was but that was so
cool that you you flexed on them in
there that was cool as [__] that wasn't
the okay
hold on yeah okay sure I'll take the
credit but the joke is is that I know
how much his ass is worth then it's a
big house the watch is not worth his
house that was the whole [__] point
but still bro it was like a face
no no that didn't make sense
thank you
oh [__] these two goons are the best
aren't they the whole [__] point but
still brother it was like I love they've
got a posse too like so they feel
important like Aiden you don't need
security I just don't care
you don't need a posse brother
nobody's pulling up on Aiden
someone's like can I get a picture huh
stop him yes have you seen guards have
you seen him boxed I think you may need
yeah it doesn't hurt yeah that's true
that's you know it's true
bro I'm not gonna
come on bro whatever stop being so he
doesn't get it because he goes no you
flexed on him and then xqc saying no I
wasn't I wasn't trying to flex xcc is
trying to back pedal and he's just mad
that was no no that was sick that was
sick Bro first he goes okay I'll take
the credit for that epic Flex then he
says I wasn't trying to flex that was
the joke and then aided says no but that
Flex was still but still dude
make it make sense to me please
I'll take the dub yeah what's the dub
I'm confused he's got the dope dude no
use in trying now
listen if I was flexing or not
it's a dub Hitler was right so modest he
[__] on him bro sure
man do you guys have like the whole
foursome [__] like what is that I feel
like no wonder this guy's such a [__]
like [__] I mean this is what happens
when you're surrounded by absolute
yesmen
butthole looking freaks dude
I [__] on him
is it [__]
[__]
would it be [__] on yeah does he know
that or is he is that like a meme
it's a goof it's a goof it's a goof it's
not being so modest he [__] on him
bro
do you guys have like the whole [__]
what is that I feel like
this is like a like I mean look at this
it's all he can think about
this man landed and he's immediately
talking about it he he
it's okay man just just own it that you
took it out today and that's how you
learn and grow yesterday Monday
secret floors something like that
oh
I want to say I stand by you bro when
you react to a video The Creator the
original Creator can literally claim the
video and take all the money that's what
that's what it is
yeah clearly we've uh made progress here
like kids on the playground
that's what I said
ah these morons
dude we just had like an hour and a half
conversation about it
so stupid and if they're really small
I'll help them out I'll [__] I'll do
whatever they want me to do because like
it's all about like it's all about me
it's all about my content what about my
content Vince is still waiting for a
response to your DM brother
it's me
is this xqc right now
The Watch
uh
is that he's reacts to videos but he the
the small creators get mad when he
reacts to them but the small creators
can it's not even the small creators
it's everybody right it's everybody you
don't get to steal anybody's content
anybody that's it you should ask for
permission first
given the quality of a react that he
does which essentially is re-uploading
claim his video and take it take the
money that's from his video it was crazy
it's not even them that are complaining
it's the people that that are have no
part in it I know you keep saying that
but like that's not true
there are people complaining you just
don't want to see them
this this conversation didn't come from
The Ether I think it started from
someone complaining
and then Vince complained who you're
ignoring yeah yeah bro I'll be honest
man I just hate the internet sometimes
for a lot yeah bro I'm gonna mess with
you I think we're too young for this
[__] and the people are too old for the
[__] that's how it is well maybe your 30
year old ass Aiden's [__] 23 at least
he has an excuse for being a dumbass
yeah I'm sleeping with like full grown
ass beards and [__] and like you know
what the [__] you talking about let's go
yeah if you got [__] gray hair and
kids should be on [__] Twitter man
yeah get off the internet get off that
[__] his bodyguards must think this is
just the weirdest job huh
I feel like what the [__] is this I
follow this kid around
not funny or interesting
he sits at the black Tech table loses
two hundred thousand dollars
what's happening
get this
oh yeah I I heard of this a little bit
but this is live
I'm Legion are you gonna do it are you
gonna I'm gonna do a desk option
tomorrow perhaps yeah yeah I guess I got
some stuff to address I'm saying okay
cool he'll be up and running tomorrow
working yo Aiden let me secure this uh
elevator for you
all right come on dude you're good
all right cool though I could just
always do IRL no problem you've got your
backpack oh no okay I'm saying you could
use mine I'm not using it
this whole Posse thing must they must
feel so important you know what I mean
yeah but there it is
clearly uh we've had some good progress
here on the fair use conversation
[Applause]
um
that's about it oh here's the sub I
wanted to look at and then this is the
last thing I'll talk about about xqc
oh here this is this is sweet actually
okay
oh he said I laughed I smiled and
laughed for the first time in a while
without having to force anything fun
time to date with Aiden I think we go
big tomorrow I'm just grateful for today
well that's nice
love these two guys man
glad he can make you laugh and put a
smile on your face brother
[Music]
yeah but this sub's pretty good again I
don't know what's going on on the X Q
cow subreddit
but they're all watch memes
uh
I don't know whatever yeah here it is
it's just this [__] awesome
this one awesome
addict addicted beware okay that's it I
don't know so that's it that's all I
have to say about that topic
any questions any comments
any concerns
thank you guys
I gotta say I got a little tiny bit of a
bone to pick with Hassan
tomorrow do you
because I was watching his response
to the debate and he's running D for xqc
a little bit
and I think he's dead wrong and so
Hassan you better be ready tomorrow boy
because I'm gonna respectfully disagree
with you okay
unlike I will very respectfully disagree
with you
look forward to that
uh so up next we've got
um Mr Beast sued for 100 million
let's go
uh so Mr Beast you guys remember he sued
I remember him yeah you guys heard of
him
Mr Beast
he got or he sued this ghost kitchen
company for 100 million for serving raw
meat and all this kind of [__]
so then they said no you
we're suing you for 100 million dollars
over breach of contract
[Music]
um
let's listen to the article Mr Beast
sued for 100 million dollars over breach
of contract by company running his ghost
kitchens okay
by Molly Bohannon oh Top Line Shadow
Molly YouTuber Mr Beast is being sued by
the company that runs Mr Beast Burger a
virtual restaurant chain and it's that
is actually pretty cool for
accessibility like for yeah no that's
good that is really cool yeah so um key
facts virtual dining Concepts a
subsidiary of virtual celebrity virtual
dining
has filed suit against Mr Beast
the suit alleges Donaldson didn't meet
promotional obligations and goes further
to say he made disparaging comments
about Beast burger and VDC that caused
irreparable harm pointing to a number of
now deleted tweets in which Donaldson
said he wanted to end the partnership
and signed a bad deal well listen
first of all I can say
as an audience member this man
promoted the [__] out of Beast Burger
you know at a certain point yeah dude a
lot it was in like ever all tweets
videos everywhere and at a certain point
look if your food is is causing a health
risk to his audience I think he's
morally obligated to stop sending people
to eat raw chicken and raw ground beef
you know yeah I'm not sure about that
one guys it was reasonable
VDC argues in the suit that the
restaurant Mr Beast burger and Company
suffered a damaged or destroyed
reputation from Donaldson's statements
yeah it's called you suck
including losing vendors supplies and
customers that caused damage in the nine
figure range
nine figure range
so wait nine figures wouldn't that be a
hundred million no way shut up
how many Beast burgers for would 100
million what's a beast Burger cost five
bucks
what's 100 million divided by five
well but they're saying they're losing
vendors suppliers like people like other
businesses don't want to work with them
anymore no they probably shouldn't
spend a million I guess yeah
oh it's 20 million right just 20 million
Beast Burgers actually I can see him
selling that many
really
I mean it's all over America it's Jimmy
B even I hate that [__] and I'm border
like four times
you know they open in Sweden too so whoa
really one in Sweden
well guys I guess it sucks to suck
the suit comes just one week after
Donaldson sued virtual dining Concepts
seeking to end the relationship arguing
that they were giving customers low
quality products delivering late and
unbranded packaging that's all true it
happened to me
there were sometimes inedible Donaldson
was seeking the immediate right to end
the deal
an undisclosed monetary damages
uh
this case is about a social media
personality who believes his Fame means
that his word does not matter shut up
sounds like kevcav [__] that the
facts do not matter that he can reneg
and breach on contractual obligations
without consequences shut the [__] up I
hate people that talk like that he is
mistaken that's giving kavcav DM energy
[Laughter]
laughs
just you know just own up man your [__]
sucks
so let's see
I guess they warned him they said beast
don't sue us
said it's listen and ill-advised
okay so apparently this is what he said
that he's now deleted that they're
saying was they didn't even say
defamatory they said
it was just uh
disparaging the company I partner with
won't let me stop even though it's
terrible for my brand it's not that bad
well I mean I don't know it was getting
him a lot of heat and a lot of oh yeah
tension we talked about it I was like
why are you still doing this I genuinely
was wondering why are you doing this
this [__] sucks man right and he's got
such a you know squeaky clean image and
everything that being associated with
like salmonella is definitely Mr Beast
and salmonella go together like peanut
butter and jelly
so yeah I mean but um coming from
probably worth it even just to break the
contract it's just doing too much damage
to his To His Image I see uh chatter
just said that uh when
uh Emily Baker was talking about this
she compared it to capcav she did yeah I
love her
she's such a bright she's so uh you know
she's so cool she sees everything she
sees the truth thank you very perceptive
thank you thank you cash cab you a
[__] [__]
I'm angry glad I had the opportunity to
do some good Kafka press on Howard's
show as well yeah yeah spread the word
spread the gospel yeah I don't know if
you guys know this but if you type
uh Ryan Kavanaugh into Google or Bing or
whatever you like google.com google.com
yahoo.com what about askg what about
yahoo.com actually have we checked this
one yeah I think our number I think it's
in uh we're top three on all of them
yeah let's type Ryan Kavanaugh let's see
what what's if Yahoo can provide us yo
Yahoo has got us no
[__] bro number two for me oh maybe you
you visited before I can go uh or
something let me do uh Incognito it's I
just did it and I
oh wait
never mind it was the top result yeah
yeah I missed it yahoo is a very
reputable
they also had it down at the bottom I
missed the one because it's such a good
website they're probably linking to one
of our sub pages
something because here's the thing
that's awesome
and I mean you could even see the number
two searches Ryan Cavanaugh Harvey
Weinstein
well I mean proving that the confusion
is real yeah
Ryan Kavanaugh Ethan Klein I mean lower
on the list because clearly our
association is not that big of a deal
right
why Mario
he's saying Yahoo
oh Yahoo go of course
love that song you're a good man
yeah no Yahoo is a good uh search engine
they know what they're doing
but obviously the majority people use
Google so let's do that Google
.com
Ryan Kavanaugh go ahead type that in
your browser guys and remember to write
the name let's Google some Isis videos
no
what let's not do it
then click the URL if you don't mind and
uh I guess it's under some heavy it's
not loading love oh yeah it's probably a
high load it's getting a lot of it's
getting a lot of views but honestly it
doesn't really matter according to
Google Just click on it
we've done our job yeah don't worry
about the content of the website it's
fine no well the content is good wait
for it read it spend some time there
it's kind of like a vibe there you spend
some time keep it open 30 seconds is a
good good indicator for Google to know
that so valuable site no no no you mean
30 seconds is how much you need to spend
to get the minimum amount of information
right exactly what I mean yeah not about
anything else than that no of course
there it is love them shut up
all right what else we got
we got sniperwolf Darman [__]
we got man exposed for sniffing girls
asses that one was crazy that wasn't
really crazy uh there was some stuff
that we skipped over up in the Goofs and
gaffs too if you want to Circle back to
any of that
yeah we can do the fan render
this was pretty wild how accurate this
was
this dude made a render of our office
and like
at this moment it's
it's close pretty much
pretty much right on we got the cups
some parts at the back yeah yeah you're
gonna see in a second
okay so that so far it's really really
and this obviously was before we just
did the recent uh
see right there oh this is it actually
goes quite a bit further back this is a
huge mistake you guys
yeah this is this is not Oculus is
really bad this part though they've got
the roof what the [__] that's just fully
accurate that's nuts man enemy's table
over there we got the big rat the gym
the H3 gym the piggies table the biggest
shout out I guess creepy a little bit
this is what lovebot used to see when
everyone went home yeah
so shout out to uh
Aardvark with a saw
shout out shout out to the hard work oh
this is interesting uh Turner this was
going on now this is the guy who exposed
Mr Beast right quote unquote exposed he
called into our show uh yes he was the
editor for Mr I think more famous for
being a big brother contestant right and
he was on Big Brother and a fupa Trooper
who friended the show friend of the show
yeah and here he went out to the
infamous slide in Boston to do an
in-depth
Field Report analysis now let's take a
look what's going on H3 Nation my name
is Turner I've been on the podcast about
a year ago but today we are in Boston
most notable for the tea party but
second most notable for the viral Tick
Tock slide right behind me David show
him what it is well today we have one
single goal for the H3 family and that
is we're gonna see if it is possible to
go down this slide right here built for
children as fast as the policeman did in
viral Tick Tock so let's get to it let's
get some head trauma and let's see if
it's possible to die on a child I got to
say shout out he heated the call
I I really I wanted a goddamn uh
experimental video and he delivered
foreign
because again we're not understanding
how crazy that man got catapulted out of
that someone got to get out there with a
reflective thing those are super
slippery you really think it's the it's
the hazard a hundred percent air bound
as he comes flying out of the tube
there's some type of he did something
what was he shot at a cannon I mean what
how many options are there you know he
did something wrong link
oh [__] there's more Kai
he was trying to send a cop one he's not
the wrong link okay
all right so let's take a look at the
cop
you send it to me he almost hurts to
walk [__] I'll just throw it up over
here
bro that's that's so crazy I mean listen
he flies like 20 feet off the ram
how does that
I think there's a lot to do with the
fabric
s
yeah you can see him going up on the
right side of the slide
connecting to the slide right now no the
velocity it just can't be it can't be
there's not enough we need we need to
find him we need to talk to him oh
interview the cop if anybody knows this
cop do you see kind of what happened
though at the end there the The Edge
kind of catapults him well right when he
comes out yeah so the edge saved his
life no I mean when he comes out of the
hole he hit it hard yeah that is what
makes him fly look on the back side
like he almost flies off completely
right yeah that would have got really I
feel like injured well did we know that
he didn't yeah do we know we have to
find him oh yeah
okay like this so this one is this isn't
what I'm thinking
yeah touch the reflect the reflection
this part yeah yeah that is pretty slick
iron but yeah completely polished
anyway let's let's continue the video
pain is actually setting in like no joke
this isn't even for camera bro my ass
really hurts right now severe bruising
he said dude I'm not even kidding when I
say my ass is killing rate myself I feel
like everyone's going down this normally
but no one's going down the way the cop
went down so you're gonna commentator I
just hope I do not have to take brother
to the hospital he's entering the slide
all right I think he's in the slide now
we're hearing bro come out backwards
yeah and he came out on his belly
I think maybe bro was just built bigger
and bouncier it's his clothes bouncier
yeah with my cameraman so after going
down the slide four or five times and
being here for about 30 minutes
specifically waiting for the adults to
show up because again this is a kid's
playground I think it's safe to say that
bro was built different obviously you
know the video recently the cop going
down the slide of course I wanted to
recreate that but I cannot find out how
the [__] he was able to get that much
speed also have you ever heard of the H3
podcast I
probably not
by his tone probably not
I don't know podcast to go down that
fast
um I went down in the silkiest clothes I
could find oh okay his recommendation
okay for me I guess that shirt does look
pretty silky yeah I don't know I really
want and and thank you by the way uh
this was a phenomenal report yes thank
you Turner
Turner thank you so much this was this
was very useful
t-u-r-n-u-r-r on Instagram
but uh if somebody again in the Boston
area we need
first of all we need to do it with like
skiing outfit yeah and then we need to
potentially and maybe you guys can stop
me if this is a bad idea but applying
some kind of lubricant to their you know
what I I was looking at this video and
it's wet it's humid that's not good
that's no good because everyone knows
who's been on a slide when it's kind of
wet that stops you immediately yeah no
shoes dry as [__]
and a [__] reflective West and you're
gonna fly out like that cop dead do you
think it would be irresponsible to Slick
the slide if I was there I'd do it we
could take a dummy like a weighted dummy
well I'm just afraid about kids going
down the next day and getting like
distressed
destroyed
bring out some
Sailors oil or whatever I was just sent
a video turn it up thank you it's
probably the uh
the best Recreation I've seen so far
this one is pretty good oh
it's still not quite to the cops level
but it's close here take a look
standby
[Laughter]
oh wait why so so why so short let me
talk to them
I think they
I mean is It sped up
[Music]
but they no because they I don't think
so yeah no that looks natural why do
they always end it I need more
information I need to talk to them
that's not bad that's the best
Recreation I've seen so far no it's not
bad he he's right on frankly
or she okay
beautiful nice
well done that's my city Boston baby
it's all happening in Boston I love that
dirty water
I was literally just gonna [__] say
that again thank you
um AI edit of the crew as Legos
have you seen this this is so you've
seen this have you heard about this
thing it's absolutely crazy wait I look
good
yeah yeah they like cleaned me up kind
of
like that Ela
she looks fire hot
Lena I mean it's pretty good yeah that's
good pretty good there's some very
cursed ones in here wait who's this I
don't even know who this is Meant To Be
So This is Love yep oh that one's not
that one's not feeling like I'm gonna
turn them into like
Swedish nationalist fashionist love yeah
yeah I guess that Swedish flag is a dead
giveaway I love allini over here this is
Dan this is Dan I'm assuming with a cute
little kind of nose yeah I was wondering
about that uh what's the AI trying to
say about my nose nobody else has their
nose that sticks out like that I
wouldn't take it personally I don't know
Pinocchio before the lies
is this Olivia no I think that's Sam oh
God oh my God Samuel she got a little
baby that's stunning yeah stunning
okay okay that's weird because it looks
like here yeah and then they just like
did a Lego filter on you I love this
area because it makes everything that
looks like a human to a little human
like in the background right it's made a
little character back there
[Music]
yours is good man right odd looks like
guts I don't want your beard as red but
that hair is crazy Zacky boy
as [__] dude I I'm so flattered by that
one
wait I am cam is a little little girl
a little grandma
did you turn in your tests oh Mr
verified himself that's powerful that is
good that is good
Jimmy I got the airline right better
rules
oh it's probably the best Martin
that one is clearly we all know who that
is PMP of course
oh uh Swedish outfit yeah Ikea boy
this one's better Dan
yeah's kind of crazy again yeah that's
the one of me screaming not everybody
always posts okay
this is Jimmy Lee and a version of Ethan
that oh it's frankly or is that Gary
I think it's me no I think that's
supposed to be even yeah look at us just
a couple guys
by the way Jimmy was uh flattered that
you brought him up on the podcast oh
yeah
yeah oh you did I forget how that
happened oh yeah one of Howie's crew
members was at the live show it was a
fan was thanking him so much and he said
he even got a tomato
I started talking about nice nice yeah
we gave we gave Jimmy a shout out
this is good
somebody made us the H3 hater bingo card
and I do think that this is going to be
a really good
kind of a post conversation
analysis like we can do this with xqc
let's take a look here
[Music]
so did he call me fat
um
I don't think so
there was one part where he like rapid
fire was throwing a bunch of insults at
you I don't remember if that was in the
mix
um it bald was yeah I don't remember
because that one stands out because it's
just like wait what hates exercise I
don't think he hit me on that
ugly
I don't think so well I mean he insulted
in your appearance I guess yeah
generally
well old is its own category right yeah
so okay Ethan he did say okay we got
that one for sure so he did make fun of
but not in the debate does that count
it's a hitter Bingo he's a hater so I
think it counts okay yeah I think it
counts is somebody marking these off
here I'll do it right now Cam's got you
woke
in the future I could even set this up
as a graphic that I have pop up during
the debate that would be and that could
be phenomenal just like just real quick
just every time so anyone gets uh axed
off he didn't hit me on the woke he did
hit me on Hassan yeah for sure he did
not hit the Fallen fan he did hit the
hypocrite hard oh big time he had old
hard he hit the divorce
no Trisha didn't hit the Jew we almost
got that that cross there didn't hit the
Jew right Teddy fresh he hit
fell off
in a way I think he kind of did what'd
he say well he was like talking about
like your audience right well maybe
maybe because the watch DM was kind of
like when you're broke and your career
is over I broke [__] so I guess we can
give him fell off maybe
I don't think he called it Ela ugly
but he did kind of go after her right
maybe it should just be like insult
insult yeah yeah why are you worried
about my wife because I feel like that's
a whole basket
yeah unfortunately I don't think we got
a bingo there though can we see the
final card yeah here cam I think just
sent it did he say divorce or no I can't
no no
wait he did yeah he did say divorce yeah
he said divorce yeah then we gotta bingo
I think well really I don't know no he
never called me ugly no because oh he
didn't pull up the card pull up the card
the divorce thing I think that was you
that said divorce you were like oh
you're going you're going through all
the things that everybody always says
what next am I I'm getting a divorce no
no but it's because he was like
oh you should leave him I had you know
okay I mean I guess that counts all
right when we go to Bingo but okay but
if he didn't call me ugly yeah we didn't
get him well when did he call me I saw
the chat saying he kind of did I I don't
know when I I you know I'm being I want
to be really uh sincere about this right
in fact we can analyze our previous
debates now too to see if we have any
bingos okay we could send prizes he
talked about your hairline that's not
ugly that's
[Music]
possum
called me a possum I remember that he
did yeah he called me an opossum that's
kind of that's cool costumes aren't ugly
I mean I think that they're cute but
they're generally considered ugly yeah
see there you go a B I think has the
opossums are kind enough all right we
might be stretching it a little bit
sweet little creatures those are scary
ugly [__] oh they're so
beautiful dude they are little they're
cute but they are a little scary that's
what makes them beautiful all right so
we'll give him on the ugly
I think that's the only fair way I
personally you know in the interest of
of being as Fair
as possible I don't remember feeling
that he called me ugly Indian
um kidding are we pulling if he called
you ugly or are we asking if possums are
ugly no no did he call me ugly yes or no
and you can interpret that however you
want good
I think there's
squares missing like you know bringing
up past controversies like the NRA stuff
or
Shapiro stuff I feel like that's brought
up a lot too these are all really good
though so it's hard to I wonder what I
guess hates exercise
fat maybe that's one category yeah you
could group those together
fat slash hates exercise
um did xqc call him ugly I'm gonna say
no wow overwhelming say yes yeah it
seems Seems like it's a yes sorry xqc I
was always on your side on this one
buddy
it was implied they say okay
he implied it
so then we have a we actually have a
winner wow and got Bingo dude he almost
won three ways so
that's good
shout out
can we print this out with a picture of
xqc and then let's do one for like Pearl
and then we can print out each one's
hater bingo card right
Pearl I think it's pretty much all let's
let's clear the board and let's think
let's do it for pearl
it was long wait he did call me soy soy
means whoa cause doesn't it or does it
mean beta it's more like yeah it's more
like beta but see that's also good
there's there's overlap there's a Venn
diagram there but yeah
you guys I agree uh like beta or soy
should be a category I'm really I had no
idea laughs wait you don't want to do
one for Pearl I was just saying I I
won't remember the details of what she
said as well
it's uh
girl's gonna get a bingo
really did she ever call me fat I don't
think so
see I don't remember did she ever say I
hate exercise I don't think so I
wouldn't dare say bad things about men
no not me it goes against her I'm a
minor ideology
right wait I don't think she's scoring a
lot she never called me ugly she may
have said okay
that does that count as okay Ethan I'd
say yeah yeah
if you never made fun of my Tourette's
she does think I'm woke that's for sure
yeah
she did did she didn't mention a song
she's not oh she is a fallen fan she
mentioned Frenemies
right she did you used to love watching
Frenemies right
um which does that Autumn does that
automatically give the Trisha box too
down below yeah I think it might that
one Thor I think Trisha yeah she
mentioned Trisha
although it wasn't like in a like oh you
worked with Trisha so you're right
which I think was the intention of this
well if we give the Tricia I think we
got it because if you look at that
bottom right corner
she called it yeah she's not she's older
than 24. oh I guess but she called her
ugly or she just said anything she
effectively does yeah you're over the
hill you're you're you're used up if
you're over that I think you can I think
you can extract that from her stance he
didn't make fun of me being Jew
shouldn't make fun of Chetty fresh oh we
got to give her the jew though she did
the Jew song yeah oh she did do this
definitely anesthetic
we haven't talked about that but we
never talked about this yeah
I had it in leftovers last week and send
it to me instead we argued about fair
use for now okay well send it to me it's
still good
okay so here is Pearl's final board and
actually she got quite lucky with this
Bingo because
xqc had a lot more points she didn't
really say anything also she spent a lot
of time scrambling um I don't think she
got the okay
I'll be honest yeah I think we're
stretching it I think we're stretching
all of them ugly wife is a stretch yeah
Trish is a stretch yeah
she was very respectful if you think
about it compared to xqc
[Music]
Sebastian's got to be a bingo
well keemstar is a full board I was just
thinking about right oh let's do a
keemstar one and then we'll move on he
has to be the full board let's do the
keemstar I want to see keemstar
literally has like a sound bite for each
other you're probably right
all right fat yes
hates exercise yes
ugly yes has he said okay Ethan right
that's I feel like yes I mean he's
talked about you in a lot of videos we
don't have proof you can hear you yeah
okay okay [__] guys we don't have proof
yeah listen Ethan wait has he made fun
of my Tourette's he must oh yeah many
times many times how many Twitter videos
about it yeah many times
uh woke yes Hassan yes or Hussein what
does this one say Fallen fan yes
he's still a fan to be honest hypocrite
every day every single day hypocrite old
yes
divorce yes Trisha yes Jew yes yes
fell off yes ugly wife yes he has a
total blackout except for okay Ethan we
gotta
find it if somebody finds it we can have
a full blackout
wow congratulations
nice a total Flawless Victory almost
high score wow nobody's ever gonna top
that
good job man
be proud of that
I hate keemstar me too I mean nah
nah murderer
all right let me watch this Pearl stuff
because we've been putting this off for
a minute and I really love this clip so
Pearl went on Piers Morgan
who's a douche
and she's been like a regular
contributor to his show I think this is
her third time calling in
she's in person it's not even a call
right oh she's living in England she's
living in the UK yeah okay that makes
sense
so
[Music]
I think they must have some kind of
understanding about what he'll talk
about and what he'll because she's so
shocked no she's horrified when he pulls
up this Jew song
and confronts her about it because I I
think she thought they were friends or
something and peers kind of threw her
under the bus he thought she thought
he's one of us yeah I have a tweet from
her from after
um Saint Pierce Morgan's producer told
told it was
this is good grammar here Piers Morgan's
producer told it was a pro-free speech
debate they set up their guests and lied
to me about who I was debating until
right before and falsely defamed me as
anti-Semitic
how about this just don't do like uh
what about the Jews song and you don't
have to worry about it listen if you
this is my advice to you and I I carry
myself with this mentality too
if you've done a what about the Jews
song always be ready to talk about it
I've done horrible offensive things in
my past and I'm always ready to talk
about that right yeah don't get caught
off guard because we're gonna ask yeah
because she's new to this and they have
every right to ask about it right and I
have a
I have every obligation to explain it so
that's my advice to you uh pearly well
she has a great explanation this clip so
let's see I think she handled it really
well Davis is the self-style
anti-feminist influences creating major
Buzz online with a contrarian view she's
appeared in a couple of debates on this
show well it is they didn't lie it says
hate speech versus Free Speech it just
so happens that she's on the hate speech
side since it afterwards I love how they
frame this controversial YouTuber
releases anti-semitic song inspired by
Nick Fuentes that sounds pretty bad
pearly honestly held opinions well this
week she's facing a major backlash of
posting a song titled why can't we talk
about the Jews all right commentator
Nick Fuentes deleting it why are you so
like just roll with it can you not look
like blindsided you're so bad it does
that a lot it's weird she looks like the
character from Recess
all right show yeah I do which character
oh I forgot her name recess she has like
negative media training they're like
okay if you get surprised by something
look shocked aghast and speechless oh
right
oh my God oh the the glasses girl yeah
yeah okay I don't even care once you go
anti-semitic it's kind of game on yeah
well this isn't the most brutal takedown
okay I've ever heard you could say it
but I just not sure I agree 100 that's
fine though they're gingerly
gingerly yeah
look how dumb she looks Jews
[Music]
without getting kicked off of you too
now I'm not saying Hitler was a good guy
well you're crazy
you're not saying that hold on Ethan
give her a chance okay all right maybe
let me let me let her finish let me yeah
let her finish let her finish let her
cook
[Music]
oh wait start can we get up there was a
butt after the butt after the not saying
hello we disavowed this morons
yeah maybe that's a good idea I disavow
also I'm Jewish I don't tolerate this we
are criticizing it we are disavowing it
we do not support anti-Semitism you
should not be anti-semitic do we have it
up thank you thank you dumbass alert all
right here we go
[Music]
now I'm
being Hitler was a good guy okay woof
[Music]
now there's all these conspiracy
theories
before they talk things
either right I love that pierce plays
the extended version too he really likes
it run yeah
[Music]
but I can't even listen to the convo
well that's pretty vile girl
it's not great you gotta I mean listen
you can't have it both ways you can't
have your cake and eat it too if you
want to go do anti-semitic songs and
sticks
you don't also get to be a part of
mainstream media and pretend like you're
not like an anti-semitic freak racist
troll Freakazoid that that's
that's [__] sickening
what she just did well I agree and to be
fair I mean it's pretty much on par with
well is it I mean everything she says is
vile sure yeah I agree but yeah I just I
don't know as a Jewish person to see so
much mainstream anti-semitic yeah no
it's it's pretty disturbing
anti-Semitism is hot hot hot right now
boy Hot Topic
what's going on with all the Jews it's
only a matter of time before we see that
what's with all these Jews actually no
Chappelle did that he did do that oh he
did stand up
yeah you know the bit I'm talking about
yeah yeah yeah
I'm not saying Jews own everything I'm
just saying we can't talk about it right
folks
Jay-Z even on his um it was a few years
ago at a record there was some
anti-semitic good was it the one the
story of O.J yeah yeah I love that song
but I was I always raised my eyebrow and
he's like there's a reason to choose
everything yeah we need to be more like
them right exactly that song is Iconic
though but uh creepy I mean and and
Michael Jackson did it too he has a song
where he says don't Jew me right like
straight up he says don't Jew me this is
the caseler in it too
the casler
that's a bad word for a Jewish person
okay slur he does yeah but like not and
he's not using it is he he says it right
he says it yeah no obviously the the
song is like an anti oh is he saying it
ironically like don't Jew me as in don't
say that look up the lyrics
I don't think
okay as as Dan researches Michael
Jackson Let's watch this joins me now
along with the New York uh author and
founder of Ender Jew hatred Brooke
Goldstein oh no he brought out a gold
state gold steam he brought out a gold
Steam from Andrew hatred that's the
Bowser of this situation guess what
guess what [__] you brought this
Goldstein on yourself that is worse than
Bernstein my friend
you're about to get cooked
you've come on the show a couple of
times right we've had some spirited
debates about feminism and stuff like
that and I thought you've made some good
points and it's got lots of traction
then I wake up the other day and I see
this thing that's trending involving you
doing this song I do I do think however
that
the stuff she is saying about women is
all I don't think people are
appreciating how [__] up and violent
also is crazy yeah I love how it is like
that is cool we can have a spirit update
about that yeah yeah you make some good
points about women not being able to
vote yeah actually I can meet you in the
middle you know it's like every
everything is bad Pierce
and I couldn't really believe what I was
watching I didn't know why why did you
find you're very funny
huh
every time you're crushing it girl
you're doing great sweetie and I
couldn't really believe what I was
watching I didn't know dude anybody
funny
huh did you find you find it funny huh I
mean you know the backlash today I mean
you deleted it he obviously thought you
shouldn't have posted it why did you do
that
I mean the point was more about cancel
culture and people getting uh
it's a song about
cancel culture Stone
yeah why did we cancel Hitler when he
was right that's the song All I'm saying
is maybe we should look into what he was
saying maybe it wasn't so bad she just
wants to know why
when she hits it with the why
it's so ridiculous here is the lyrics to
um
the Michael Jackson song kick me oh my
God it's in the title No Okay I uh I've
been looking through the keemstar
podcast to see if he says okay Ethan at
any point and so I haven't been hearing
the show and I just look up and see
Michael Jackson lyrics what did I miss
yeah so I was just talking about how and
this song They Don't Care About Us yeah
he drops some really eyebrow raising
language he says
beat me hate me you can never break me
will me thrill me you can never kill me
Jew me Sue me everybody do me I don't I
think he's using it in the derogatory
way
oh
kick me I don't even know if I could say
that word it's the k word
bat me don't you black or white me
like is there any way to interpret this
where he's not just using it in the
derogatory sense kick
well there's a genius annotation that
tries to explain it the line generated a
lot of controversy but MJ did not mean
it as an anti-semitic remark in the song
Michael is speaking from the point of
view of everyone who's ever been
persecuted for example for being Jewish
or black but with this line and the
previous line Juni MJ is trying to get
the point across that people can label
or throw whatever abuse they want at
Social minorities but he will stand up
and speak out against their hate
I see that I see that but I also I'm
having a hard time with the way it's
phrased here giving I am Jewish I I
agree with you Ethan like I
I
it's weird it says everybody do me
because this is the perspective from the
person who's oppressed they're saying
you can beat me you can hate me you can
never break me exactly you can Will me
thrill me you can never kill me and then
the oppressed person is saying you can
Jew me
you can sue me everybody do me the the
oppressed person is saying you can Jew
me but I'll survive
right but then in the next line flips it
and is speaking as if they are a Jewish
person who is being having slurs hurled
up okay I can see that
k word me kick me k word me
or maybe he just really he wanted to
double down maybe I don't know I don't
know all right Michael I get the point
though it's a beautiful message right
oh I gotta say is they don't really care
about us they don't right
the Bell is so funny
they sure don't back to Pearl social
media if you finish the song it was more
about like you can't talk about this
topic without being canceled by the left
and the right I don't really wait wait
hold on hold on
it's a song about Council culture
literally why can't we just talk about
were the numbers greatly exaggerated and
it was Hitler a good guy without being
canceled
awesome Point girl
why can't I just talk about how I
believe we should go back to uh 1800s
and enslave African-Americans again
without being canceled
it's about cancer culture
it's so stupid and also just
like two or three years behind the curve
on like
a canceled culture like nobody else on
the right is bitching about cancel
culture anymore like they've moved on
remember
yeah there's other stuff move on woke we
moved on to woke what do you care about
cancel culture in fact we love canceling
things now we're canceling Bud Light
we're canceling Target we're canceling
anything that pisses us off so cancel
culture is actually good I think she's
just scrambling
yeah I mean she's an idiot so yeah oh
ab's bringing out the Michael receipts
uh in defense of of uh his dear dear I I
I'm kidding maybe I'm gonna read it
Michael's Michael Michael said in an
interview
the idea that these lyrics could be
deemed objectionable is extremely
hurtful to me and misleading the song is
in fact about the pain and Prejudice and
hate as a way to draw attention to
social political problems I am the voice
of the accused and the attacked
okay
so the voice of uh
some other so moving on I am the voice
of everyone I am the skinhead I am the
Jew
well why okay
you are the skinhead I am Jewish
or skinheads are famously oppressed
he says I'm a skinhead I'm a Jew I'm a
black man I'm a white man I am gay
what year was this written in
oh he says I'm the voice of the accused
95 yeah I don't know because like yeah
he he I'm glad he's representing the
skinheads
I am not the one who was attacking it
was about the Injustice to young people
and how the system promptly accused them
I'm angry and outraged that could be so
misinterpreted okay
yeah I mean that's crazy because people
think you raped kids but that's also you
didn't do that so that's a huge
misunderstanding that was even a bigger
misunderstanding frankly
that's crazy oh come on man
inappropriate
all right oh [__] no I didn't want to
finish that
control T does it work I'll talk about
it says
for the record I sent that before Dan
read the actual nation and the lyrics
I appreciated it I appreciated it you
find it funny I mean you know the
backlash well it was more like why can't
we talk about it it wasn't like
conspiracy theories you've heard about
Hitler and the Holocaust I'm a fan of
conspiracy theory like you know people
think I'm part of the CIA there's a
whole conspiracy thing online and you
know nobody believes that
she said that's so crazy oh nobody
believes that
I'm not for like silencing it either way
the point of the song isn't like I
really have an opinion on the matter
it's more
I don't think we should ban squash of
social media nice try dummy let's see if
Pierce Morgan can actually like pin her
on this because she's obviously lying
or so that I don't even like I think it
should be illegal to ban anybody off of
social media I'll allow that I'll love
it I'm cool with that
unless they're inciting violence that
was the point of the song I mean you're
pretty close yeah it is you're getting
there I'm pretty close it's getting
there yeah yeah long um I'm not really
it was more like tongue and just to be
clear what are the conspiracy theories
surrounding Hitler which you feel I
don't know you hear them the more you're
interested in them well I don't know
good question good question we need to
pin her down it annoys me how good
Pierce is at this sometimes like I don't
like him I don't like his opinions but
we talked about this before because he
occasionally does this he'll have even
shittier people than him on his show and
he genuinely is good at pinning them uh
on their [__] I think you don't want
to like him UK journalists are like
think about when Ben Shapiro lost his
mind and he was being grilled by like a
very conservative UK person that's true
yeah yeah the UK press is way more harsh
than America not even harsh competent
it's like let's get right it's actually
got people to talk about something in a
genuine way right oh because I can't
hear them you know the ones that Nick
fuented well I wasn't even talking about
Nick I was thinking of yay to be honest
I don't know why okay what about the one
that was the inspiration for that song I
was thinking of yay okay you are aware
of the big backlash today
we're working together Pierce just
missed a huge opportunity he's letting
her go with this [__]
[Music]
what I would have said is okay what
about yay then what is the conspiracy
theories that you find interesting
forced her to explain she likes uh
um Connie's version of Auntie says the
anti-Semitism more than Nick Yeah Yeah a
different variety even though
I think they subscribe to the same uh
Elders of Zion right they checked that
same book out at the library the upset
from Jewish Community I certainly am now
I just posted that song and I woke up
and I was like article article article I
was like golly right but are you sorry
question you know poke around the Jewish
question a little bit golly all of a
sudden everybody's jumping down your
throat these Jews are sure sensitive IGA
volt Pierce
easy
um you know I I think that
like what it my whole point was that
cancel culture is wrong I am not
speaking one way or the other about the
dude just be like okay where did you
mention which part of the song
accidental flies that
because from what I saw it's just you
talking about Jewish people
I mean she does say why can't you talk
about the Jews without getting kicked
off YouTube that is the beginning of it
so why can't you talk about the Jews
without getting kicked off YouTube right
and then she goes on to for the Hitler
so people should be the element of their
they say okay so people should be able
to talk about the Jews without being
kicked off YouTube Correct so what is it
that you think exactly they should be
able to say
right that they're getting kicked off
that they shouldn't be and why why it
doesn't really matter like she's
deflecting me like it's about cancel
culture but Pierce is correctly not
focusing on the first line he's focusing
on the follow-up of the more
conspiracies I read about Jews the more
I believe them
that's not about cancel culture well
that's not she's not even talking about
cancer that's just another conspiracy
that like you can't talk about the Jews
because they own everything and they'll
shut you down right it's not really
about that my question is someone said
screen is Frozen is that just them I
think
video is frozen oh I'm seeing video
screen yeah everybody's saying it now
seems hit play again
why are we canceled about talk for
talking about certain topics she would
allow Holocaust deniers to have space on
social media to promote a good question
denials to millions of people you have
two million people who subscribe to your
YouTube better answer that's a big
audience don't don't
and the question there by tacking on
you're giving her opportunity not to
answer it about 2 million yet I'd like
to be Robert you have a lot of people
that follow you who just gave her a
total pass on that good question
social media platform yeah you put a
video like that up and there are going
to be some impressionable young minds
going hang on what's Pearl saying Adolf
Hitler you're not saying he's a good guy
but I want to know why the more
conspiracies I I theories are here the
more I have to think about it but I took
that to me I took that to mean that you
agree with it
why did the end of the the song should
we watch the end uh I'm sure it's all
like I'm just kidding [__] Hitler love
the Jews good people the numbers under
reported if anything
like let's check out the end of that
song Let's see uh well she deleted the
tweet and it's definitely it's it's up
there you can't even have the
conversation what is the conversation
you want
to ask what are the left and the right
when is any speech I think it's not easy
what is the conversation about Hitler
thank you and conspiracy theories and
the Holocaust that you want to have
thank you don't want to have any
conversation my Lane is feminism
can I can I finish you're all singing
about it okay oh so you do want to have
that conversation I want anybody that
wants to speak on social media to be
able to speak about what they want to
talk about who's the Goldstein coming to
drop the hammer
okay here is a
let's see how let's see how this song
ends in a really uh inspiring
wait it says dedicated to Nick Fuentes
that wasn't on the original video this
is somebody who's you know tracking can
you bring up the disclaimer please thank
you
[Music]
oh you skipped to the end
yeah that's something like reacting to
it she said listen to the end
I think just it's all just this might be
two videos together yes exactly if you
scrub back
to that yeah that's now it's not playing
okay
all right are we over it I'm not I just
need to figure out what the [__] going
on yeah well drop the track
why
now there's all these conspiracy
theories yeah and the more they talk I
think
maybe they're right okay that's a pretty
pretty editorial comment honestly
expressing your opinion really really
bad compared to the steps worse yeah
yeah like she's saying I believe this
yeah
this is she literally was just like this
isn't about cancel culture I just don't
like Jews
finish it that's it that's what I would
have loved you know I believe it but I
can't even listen
I can't even have the conversation
without getting canceled by the left and
the right
why can't we talk about them
this is the part that changes
[Music]
now really
I'm not trying to be rude okay oh you're
good then
why can't we talk about
about yeah no she's right man there you
go yeah now that I'm glad I got more
context on that
Bob Dylan more like Bob Phelan
not that good
also another Jew
not anymore he's a newborn did you know
that he jumped sides
I think I guess I didn't know that yeah
he got kind of weird in his older years
he was always weird got really a lot
weirder
weird [__] dude
without getting banned whatever they
want to talk including Holly calls to
know if they want to talk about that as
long as they're not inciting violence I
think people also exciting violence
social media you know what Hitler was
like about
do you know what his like thesis was
you should look into that
if you don't think it's about that
that's the New Town Square right you
used to be able to go and say your
opinions in the Town Square now we have
yeah it used to be you go in the Town
Square say some dumb [__] and somebody
would shoot you or a [__] like mob
yeah what is this fantasy like that
there was a period in history where on a
daily basis everybody just went down to
the Town Square had open discussion get
on down to the Town Square full open
discussion pearls talking like that
maybe happened every once in a blue moon
I guess somewhere where do you think fit
in the Town Square but like this was not
this was not a regular thing
hmm
go try going to Town Square talking [__]
on the king and see what happens
your head be on a pike real fast try
that in a small town square that's right
I tell you what boy I got a couple of
floorboards with your name on them
I'm not gonna go there don't worry
corporations censoring what can and
cannot be set all right shut up dummy
where's the Goldberg I want to see her
come in oh here she is
where's the Goldberg
I know people quite understands why the
word becomes the Hebrew hammer which she
deletes it to be clear so obviously
realize this had not played out maybe
the way she hoped
um
the Jewish Community why was it so
offensive
well first of all I want to
for having me on
highlighting this issue yes not
necessarily highlighting Pearl but
highlighting the issue that what you
pointed out is that we're really facing
a crisis of societal conscious
Pearl who engages in hate speech and
actually the irony is she's complaining
about being canceled right and that
she's on your platform she has millions
of viewers
right always a good point
mm-hmm always a good point and add it on
social media and she's complaining about
being canceled the processes that this
is what is profitable now this click
bait this type of racial incitement is
profitable on the internet and you know
I'm sitting here I'm listening to Pearl
I I don't know if she's just plain
stupid all right
whatever
yeah she was really cooking you want me
to keep going I'm afraid I'm gonna get
claimed or something uh well we checked
it it didn't get close let's give her a
chance and knows that what she's doing
is so Sensational that is going to make
her a lot of money but I want to say one
thing Pearl will disappear she will
disappear like many others before her
because this is something that's just
and by the by the quality of man she's
looking to marry he's going to make her
disappear
real man beat their wives close to death
a moment in time she's like a train
wreck it's like a car crash you know for
example you can't you know you shouldn't
be looking at it but you can't take your
eyes off it but I want to make one more
point I think it's so important uh
especially on this platform
hatred is taught nobody is born like
this and I talk about nobody's born like
this dumb [__] here
that's learned yeah dangers of hate
education and it's not something that we
can debate that we can engage in a
rational argument with you can see what
her opinions are she thinks women
shouldn't vote women shouldn't have the
right to divorce he thinks that women
it's giving excuses calling me gray hair
Andy it's like dude you're on Piers
Morgan you sound like a [__] idiot
actually so dumb she has a friend
backstage I guess who she keeps looking
to for um
for uh validation God she's pathetic I
want to watch that again
or she's actually quite intelligent and
knows that what she's doing is so
Sensational that is going to make her a
lot of money but I want to say one thing
Pearl will disappear
like many others before they shouldn't
be looking at it but you can't take your
eyes off it but I want to make one more
point I think it's so important
especially on this platform
hatred is taught nobody is born like
this and I talk about it a lot in my
book about the dangers of hate education
and it's not something that we can
debate that we can engage in a rational
argument with you can see what her
opinions are she thinks women shouldn't
vote women shouldn't have the right to
divorce he thinks that women should be
able to work she says these no it
doesn't say crazy God she's such a
[__] loser
how does she look how did she look at
herself in the mirror like nobody likes
you not even the people on the right
like you are you're just like such
a worthless sack of [__]
I mean literally people say this but
it's true in this case a waste of oxygen
I like does she have feelings I feel
like for
self-preservation reasons even because
everybody hates her so much you'd think
that she'd be like okay maybe let me let
me settle down and pick a side I guess
but she's like alienating everybody
because she sucks so much
hopefully this comes back on our family
too because clearly they're she's still
living with Papa
down on Papa's range no she doesn't
anymore right I think she lives oh yeah
yeah yeah no more pop is right I think
she did maybe she got told recently
should the [__] leave the country
yeah we have no idea we have no idea
what that situation my my papi owns a
ranch called Hitler was right Ranch
closer to tape Maybe we like to come
have people down teaching about how
Hitler was right
not anti-semitic about it
just say it
it's literally like constantly
embarrassing herself hey it's
what else we got
not a lot
oh the guy the sniffer
Michaela Witter the sniffer I thought
you're gonna say sniffer wolf because we
have the sniper sniper wolf oh no this
is the girl I was gonna say let's not
put that on uh so this is the girl who
I guess now my question is here let me
let me watch her tick tocks because it
seemed like she set this up on purpose
no she caught it when she was taking a
tick tock
oh that's great because I was wondering
why she was filming she was making like
one of those artsy tick tocks like Ela
did one in a bookstore because I was
also like why are you just looking at
the first page over and over yeah if the
if you click on the original Tick Tock
she has all the footage of like The Tick
Tock she was making until oh that's so
creepy everyone so I just wanted to talk
about the situation with the creepy guy
from Barnes Noble and it just touched
base on some things like on first thank
you so much how come this is
is this not the first one in the series
The Original because this where's the
original one wait 1A and yeah 1A oh
it's not on the timeline
stay 20 of 100 days facilitates and
today oh so it's this one she did it as
part about
yeah
and today we're going to Barnes Noble
and getting started that didn't get the
main thrust of the video except I ended
up being stalks and interested the
entire time so I get to Barnes Noble and
get my Starbucks I'm super excited to
look at books but this is the area that
it started I was in this corner for a
while and I noticed the guy was staring
at me through that little hole and I
couldn't tell if I was being paranoids
like through the bookshelf ma'am yep no
that's so creepy they just happened to
be in that little corner anyways it felt
like anywhere I moved he kept falling so
I recorded just in case he was trying to
say anything or do anything to me but I
definitely didn't expect him to do that
and Ross eat your heart out brother
this is Aiden Ross when it's just him
and Andrew Andrew's like cooking oh yeah
Aiden's creeping around trying to sniff
his ass yeah
oh no this guy's a freak though I guess
trigger warning this makes you
uncomfortable yeah and I mean it will
this like what trigger warning ass
sniffing literally
actual [__] and the whole time I'm
thinking I'm fine because he hasn't said
anything or touched me or anything but
then you notice that he goes over and
does the same thing to this girl oh [__]
he's doing numbers so he's bouncing
between girls no way people responded to
this that he's like known in the area
people know that he does this
he's a local sniffer his numbers are
crazy how he just he hit both of them in
a matter of like 15 seconds boom boom
yeah yeah he does this often he's very
he's exactly he's very proficient ask
never he's doing something and then
smell I don't know and the whole time
I'm wondering why he's always around me
but this was our interaction
and what are you doing tying my shoe
I was so freaked out when I just tied my
shoe under you
turned around and saw him literally
under me so freaking close to me so I
decided to tell the front desk oh good
yeah she filed a police report good
s and he's like pretend like he's tying
shoes and I think he's like
oh
this comment from Nick says bro that's
the same guy who was crouching behind me
follow me on Marshalls today
and then I try to wash my car as fast as
possible because I don't want to run
into him so I'm leaving now but I just
watched the video back because I was
trying to figure out what he was doing
so close to me and it freaked like I'm
so disgusted and I feel like really
violated yeah I'm not gonna touch me but
it just feels really gross and weird and
then I went up to the front to tell the
lady because I didn't want him to do
that to other people and then as I was
telling her he was leaving and so all
she said that she could do was just tell
the manager I waited around a little bit
because I didn't want to run into him
and I couldn't even focus like I wanted
to get a book but then I was just like
my anxiety was just like really bad and
like also I just felt like really
grossed out so I just left as soon as I
could that's literally like so creepy
I've never had someone do that to me
it's just really weird
uh the good news is at least in this one
she has his full name and puts it out
let's see
where was that where I saw the full name
out
it's in that Tick Tock it's she's
responding to a comment that says his
name and um and also here like the city
of Glendale has released oh God he's in
La yeah this is Glendale baby oh [__] he
could be sniffing any one of our asses
it's a rainy day out here in Los Angeles
so yeah this guy has a ton
yuck does it say what he was charged for
let's see this one says prowling looking
in Windows yeah I read this before
peeping prowling
uh again oh prowling looking in bedroom
windows
uh and then again in September
was looking in kitchen windows
again he's like peeping Tom
is identified again
they had a warrant for him in 2021 they
arrested him for prowling and disorderly
conduct
remains in custody
but so he's out clearly
right this was 2021. he's out and back
snit he's he's actually he's upgraded
he's not prowling anymore he's sniffing
he's up he's up actually this dude is
probably dangerous like really dangerous
because I've watched enough True Crime
to know
that
it starts with prowling it goes to
stiffing and then it goes to yep gotcha
physical violence the end of that
warning is like everybody in the
community please like make sure to stay
safe it's like it's a warning
yeah this guy's a everybody in La look
out for this [__] he's got
Martian ears
you know like Looney Tunes so they stick
out and it looks like Shrek Shrek ears
oh Shrek is looking for some sniffs
wow I do kind of look like truck ears uh
what a [__] freak yeah I had
something similar happen to me in
college actually oh my God a sniffer
wait what we're not a sniffer but it was
in the library and I noticed this guy
kept following me around and taking
photos of me on his phone and the first
few times I'm like okay whatever I'd
walk to a different area of the library
and then there he pops up again and just
kept taking photos of me
I I was I was trying to take a picture
of something behind you you just
happened to be in the photos
[Music]
this story has a happy end ing
oh that was good no it wasn't easy but I
did I went to the security office and I
reported him and then the security guard
um walked me to my class and that's it
that's horrifying I don't know what
happened with him or if they did
anything but
so [__] disgusting God weirdo bro
yeah weirdo bro
wait where'd the sound go
uh muted in the the little icon in the
corner maybe I didn't do nothing
tick tock on PC man it's the best air
muted unmuted
refresh that's right refreshing
it's muted
it's not muted here
it's not muted on my laptop
not muted on oh
it works now okay wait what happened
somebody did something I didn't touch
[__]
a little weird like
we actually I posted on Tick Tock and
people are saying that he's done that
for them as well
if you have the image to write a
description of him gross I have a
picture of the screenshot she got
pictures damn yeah she took that video
oh yeah I forgot oh yeah his ass is on
yeah
hello oh and he did it to another girl
as well so and I have footage of it
um and like screenshots if you wanted to
take it so make sure that it doesn't
come back
yeah people are saying that they
recognize him this is exactly what I was
talking about all right
well my uh regards uh my
condolences to these
poor ladies that have to deal with these
Freaks Like Aiden Ross
for real and this guy incidentally right
yeah oh no he's in LA with the streets
of Glendale watch
stay safe yeah look out in Glendale
um she followed uh she did file a police
report is this the one yeah I think I
was just watching you got it okay you
got it
there it is there it is there's a ass
sniffer on the loose
actually we still have like 20 minutes
so let's do the sniperwolf darband
collab yes
so sniperwolf is actually being called
out big time same as xqc well you guys
know what Jack's film's been up to
really clever stuff actually let me
check in on him
um
jacket off
because last I checked his channel is
doing really good
sniper
Sniper Wolf
uh where's his second J.J jacks films
here it is bugs in Mexico so let's check
it dude the views are good
like like legitimately like 300 000 on a
Daily Post that's that's really good
he's been watching these so check it out
on a rotation right if you're familiar
with Sniper Wolf Bingo you know that all
The Usual Suspects are here right like
oh no and the fake laugh but I want to
add more squares this is my card that
I'll be playing Jack is out for blood
it's awesome I've never seen him like
this before
this is my stick usually
it's good oh this has some of the spots
that we added but not all of them it's
people who let the intrusive thoughts
win whatever that means
okay oh it's so rare but we have Tick
Tock user Navy enjoyer whoa triggering
my shaky Cam hold on is Navy and Joy or
a free Booter we gotta look at the
account Jarvis open Tick Tock for me
it's hard to tell it's very hard to tell
but it's it's actually quite
entertaining I have to say I'm subbed as
of right now this isn't my main account
it just does throw away
but um that's pretty exciting for him
I'm glad this is this is awesome
but anyway Sniper Wolf uh who I guess is
another prolific content Thief
although I'll be honest I don't even
think it's as bad as excuses because at
least
at least you can say hello friend she at
least filmed this and assembled it where
xqc literally just cuts a piece from
twitch
and uploads it to YouTube
and she talks a lot more than xuc
doesn't Stone The Avengers they
literally got do I think this is
transformative hell no
I mean but I think it's more gray it's
definitely more gray and yeah it heard
commentary maybe [__] but but I mean
that's that's uh well her well so her
comments no requirement that the
commentary be good for it to be
transformative you know what I mean it's
not that it needs to be good it needs to
be critical right or not even in the
sense that it's like analyzing yeah
analytical I mean if she analyzes it oh
they let the intrusive thoughts
English like I said this one this one
you could definitely like have a
conversation about right I don't think
it is but like but xqcs
there's no conversation I have about it
the bed in the corner okay that's fire
actually
that's dub
your side and then I actually feel like
you're falling I mean she's talking at
least and putting it together you know
so it's not as bad as xqc in my opinion
that being said the infamous
um Sniper Wolf my best friend Stella is
more happy y'all we're gonna be live
today than their birthday
thank you guys for getting them through
high school they're 18 today gotta share
the live hmm
what are we doing about this Zach it was
a 200 donation
18.
18. [__] you oh you already told that we
were
there right amount of money
okay well but it was a big donation
God bless you got it you got the the
coveted birthday shout out yeah
shout out so a sniperwolf uh teamed up
with Darman we've talked about Darman he
has a very popular YouTube channel where
he makes a very
uh pseudo inspirational videos and then
but what's interesting is he also has
like a criminal past we uncovered he is
like
did like some pretty heavy duty real
estate fraud
right and I don't speak at a time I
don't know if you should be saying no I
don't remember I just don't remember the
details according to the Mercury News
um oh my God they just gave me a goddamn
ad no that here it is here it is
a Darman sentences to five years of
probation for defending the city of
Oakland defrauding the Oakland City so
this is your boy Darman here
this happened according to the Mercury
News
and I always find this endlessly
interesting an Oakland businessman whose
work in marijuana industry earned him
the moniker ganja panuer nice has been
sentenced to five years probation for
pocketing City grant money meant to for
building improvements
what a guy what a guy what a guy he also
must pay the city of Oakland forty four
thousand dollars
he pleaded no contest of five felonies
he's like you got me
authorities say that man made phony
claims to an Oakland Redevelopment
agency grant program in place
to help Property Owners make needed
Renovations he's being sued by the city
for 230 000 with 135 000 in Damages but
you can afford that by now with this
YouTube channel you're doing
but regardless it is oh this is 2014. it
is interesting that Mr moralistic uh
he's just trying to make the world a
better place
[Music]
um
not trying to make Oakland a better
place tell you that
anyway here's the video he made with
sniperwolf I heard this was fantastic I
haven't seen it yet one of a few of them
they did a few collabs
all right this is your baby right baby
I'm I love these videos more than
anything okay
what did you get for number 23. I'm not
there yet Heather I want to watch the um
original because I want to see the
comments
I want to see how uh wait what original
what do you mean by original oh we don't
it's not on YouTube anymore oh it is
here it is yeah my bad my bad here it is
let's see 11 million views from 11
months ago this is this is big this is
19 million
what'd I say 11.
I saw a 19.
you saw the 11 months and it tripped you
up 19 million views 11 months ago Mean
Girls shame team for anime
that's not okay man
that's not okay Heather Reyna can you
stop talking and tell everyone I thought
we we oh no I thought that we were okay
with shaming um fans of anime
I thought that was socially Norm social
Norm sure it's a Chanel bag just sitting
on her desk darman's a progressive like
what the [__] that's a good ass question
what kind of high school girl is this
[Music]
I need to step out for a minute finish
your worksheets and I'll be right back
teachers the same age as all the
students she's a dumbass walked out
during number 23.
anime loser idiot
oh my God
wait a second oh no
loser dude a lot of these premises are
like so far from anything that would
ever happen is this Chase that's private
let me see
[Music]
oh my gosh it's totally him he even has
the same jacket
who's drawing her Crush I hate Chase
looks like you've got yourself a little
sucker hold the [__] phone let me go
back to the drawing yeah that wasn't the
same guy what the [__] it looked like a
generic anime guy yeah
huh that's totally oh it says Chase oh
yeah well
she made the inference from the giant
Chase caught yeah
we got you it's just me as a anime
character why the [__] would you do that
to me he's good I hate you
[Laughter]
oh he is totally in love with you
I kind of sweet I was just maybe he
feels the same drawing characters from a
series
he's looking at her like oh she got that
Demon Hunter swag on what an idiot loser
she's wearing a Demon Hunter shirt what
now human Slayer this guy's acting like
he just found a drawing of him getting
like like sexually abused
his corpse like mutilated why are you
drawing he's like so Disturbed
characters for my series
I think Chase is into it I think he's
flattered he's too shy I hope that's the
twist are you serious
just when I thought you couldn't get any
weirder anime isn't weird like 26 in
high school Ariana Grande Kanye West
Sniper Wolf and what okay
no I think they're ever gonna care about
your dumb little drawings oh sorry about
that hopefully everyone had a chance to
finish pass them up to the front please
oh and a quick reminder that Friday is
career day so you will want to dress up
as whatever you want to be lawyers
doctors astronauts sniper Wolf's gonna
come on career day is that what's
happening no maybe that's a nightmare I
think I've I'm making a prediction here
I don't know if sniperwolf is actually
going to be like uh Corporal I think
she's going to be like the spirit of
sniperwolf comes to uh encourage this
young woman like a foreign
herself yeah
yeah no I think she'll be in it but I'm
just saying within the
story world I don't think why the [__]
would you have a
twitch well I guess she's a YouTuber now
can you imagine me getting uh you know
invited for career day like listen
I don't know what to tell you guys
I don't know nothing about nobody
whatever your dream job is and then
you'll give a brief presentation to the
rest of the class I bet Mia's dressing
up as Pikachu
yeah Excuse Me Miss krenz but if you
don't plan on working well you have to
choose something anything you could be a
philanthropist if you don't plan on
working like I would ever do that to
myself
serve never mind figure something out
you better figure something out because
your ass is basically about to join the
workforce
you're pushing 30.
Chase it's so hot I love that you said
I'll never stoop to something as low as
a as a stay-at-home mom yeah
it's like I'm I'm literally just gonna
exist in a sensory deprivation I'm just
gonna do nothing I'm gonna sit at home
in the dark stare at the wall forever
yo can I tell you something figure
something out watch this
Chase is so hot right now
yeah stop stop Chase
is meal legit still drawing her anime
okay why does she have a headset on get
your phone out she's ready to game at
any moment let's hear these Mean Girls
out for a second
record me but starting maybe she is kind
of a loser yeah I mean let's
who is she talking to right wait maybe
are we siding with the bullies right now
the headset in the cafeteria together
girl dude if you're watching anime keep
it a secret like the rest of us do
[Music]
hey loser thanks for the sandwich hey
that's my lunch me oh you can keep it
how old does that mean
my mom got it from Walmart
[Applause]
that's all meat
you got any fresh meat say Joe exotic
she doesn't have a Chanel bag like our
girl over here she just has trees at
Walmart
you what are you wasting your time on
now
[Applause]
to say can you please leave me alone
we need to finish this for the contest
you really don't think this is gonna
make you any money do you I mean it
might someday you really do live in your
fantasy world you know if I were you I'd
start practicing taking coffee orders
now so that's all you're going to end up
doing if you stay on this track
crazy okay she cares about her future
that's very nice very thoughtful
yeah guidance counselor
stop taking my stuff dumb dumb
stupid
wrong perspective stay out of this
stay out of this what like she's
Voldemort or something or you're next
[Laughter]
[Music]
is this me that's you what's up
it's on now she looks pretty though
start recording [__] if that's how it's
gonna be don't do it they might as well
embrace the part
don't do it
no no no
yes that's my girl I needed these for
the contest serves you right for drawing
people without their permission and
besides anime is a total waste of time
I love how they made her look like she
didn't shower and [__] like look how
crazy she looks her hair is all crazy
looks like they oiled her hair or
something right gamer hair yeah I mean
she's [__] this camera here right
there boy
I think you know who I think doesn't
like anime people Dar man
yeah yeah we don't all look like this
it's a fake weave she looks fine she was
fine
but her hair is not combed you know what
I mean yes they do that intentionally
cinema this is Cinema I don't know why
is she wearing a wig she is right
um possibly I think she has to be she
has to be look how far I'll keep my eye
out has anyone ever come up to you and
like giving you a drawing that they did
of you in public me yeah someone's done
that to me before what it doesn't feel a
little bit weird but I was actually very
was it good I liked it it was beautiful
I feel like it was he here
I what's up was he handsome or ugly he
was an old guy okay that's less that's
not threatening yeah I feel like that
only happens in tick tocks
you know what I mean I was in high
school oh maybe maybe he was gross no he
was sweet
virgin was it anime Olivia or was it no
it was like it was like real stuff
I'm kidding
guys I'm going back a bit but uh I just
got a text from Howie he says he's a
dual citizen
get back
which is back
it's International uncle
let me see so good
I'm so sorry Mia you didn't deserve that
oh they're nice don't let her get to you
yeah right
oh
dude again
this girl would her life would be ruined
if she posted that on tick tock
like straight over oh my God yeah I've
seen oh so sorry no go ahead go ahead no
no no you go no you go no both of you at
the same time okay I'll count the three
and you both talk at the same time super
quick I've seen those jeans on Instagram
ads and I've thought that they were cute
on the ad and I'm happy that I'm seeing
them now because I don't want them I
don't think Darman is saying these jeans
so sorry AV I was just gonna say what
are these two [__] losers laughing at
that oh
how did you know that she was like from
20 feet away
you just ask people laughing what is
that yeah you're weird
thanks for the views yes
you're gonna get [__] canceled bro
that woman
I love her I don't know I have to say
it's insane she has one objective and
it's to be a [__] the production value
of his videos is weirdly high oh yes
like he's got sets props full actors
he's got like background actors it's
bizarre
yeah I'm saying he's saving money on the
actors right for the production yeah but
yeah they have a a very large facility
here in La they shoot all this in the
hell on stage
where
that they're in
by the way
like in the sketch yeah like where where
are we we're at school it's cool why is
there a barber
a Barbie look there's a Barber's pole in
the background could be vocational
school that's interesting I didn't
notice that maybe it's just uh it's
probably just like a set for everything
no
all right when did Sniper Wolf show up
I'm going to fast forward because we're
running out of time okay
this I'm just I noticed in the timeline
this is the most watched okay do you
need to leave at 4 30. I would like to
yeah
we'll watch this okay I think we got a
pin in the rest of this as well this is
a good show okay oh let's watch the
scene yeah so the mom is giving her
advice you're not that [__] weird
okay go ahead let her play She's she's
hard on herself you know
[Music]
my point is every person that's trying
to make something shut up mom lives have
to overcome
some kind of obstacle and the obstacles
are what make for a great story
why don't you go get that
is it her hero
okay yeah she met her at Walmart
nah really no okay
no okay
why are you okay
okay
she's being anime positive right but I
don't know I don't know about you guys
but when I used to be sad I was hoping
Ethan would knock on the door one day
you're wearing a kimono yeah inside the
house so already that is dressed I'd be
dressed up as like a Iman what do you
call like a Islamic uh uh creature oh a
chef a Shaq how do you say it Shack
Shack
Jack yeah I'd come to your house dressed
as a chef
uh yeah I'm sorry how do you know my
name oh my God I wish I didn't look like
this right now
you're total no
oh
it's true anime fans are weird dude you
guys are freaks right now
she's about to bust out
uego eyes or whatever
she's like girl girl you are so cool
right now
[Music]
she opens the door it's like oh you're
gonna lose her from Texas video about
you
so I reached out to your mom
you know about this that's why I was
trying to get you to go get ready oh The
Tick Tock is one I'm sorry
that Heather girl sounds like a
microwave that I went to school with
that made fun of me you know I know that
like he tells them to overact but
I don't know if it's hard to tell if
it's his direction or if she's just
really bad
you've got like 30 million subscribers
now but I wasn't very popular in high
school I was into anime and the other
girls were into boys and you like I'm
emote or so she's bad right she's yes
yeah yeah I mean she's trying her best
she's giving something she's not an
actress so right why should we why
should we yeah it's Sniper Wolf why
should I uh make sure I'm a bully victim
this is incredible it's probably
darman's fault though he has everyone
yeah I mean nobody comes across well in
these so and it's probably the direction
but now some of those same girls want to
be my friends it's funny how life works
so when people were mean to you it
didn't make you want to change not at
all because one thing I know is being
different is what makes you cool you do
not at all it never affected me because
I'm not a coward like you are
so you can fast forward to like 12
minutes uh 32 seconds 12 minutes here I
see another Peak here
now I think you better go change or
we're gonna be late wait you're going to
school with me yep tangiero nezuko gotta
stick together right yes
she's gonna get her ass beat after that
school is about to get way worse for her
so in conclusion I want to be a real
housewife
too okay girl seriously shoot for the
stars if I'm being honest
that was me clapping what end
jingle Heather well we certainly have
some colorful ideas between that and
Derek's dream job of creating a pyramid
scheme
that's cool awesome the little closer
Logan Paul is about to come to the
school
yeah the city of Oakland might have
something to say about that
his next
wanna come on
girl you need to get your ass beat
that's crazy you do not go to school
looking like that I cannot wait
well uh but they're all dressed up in
costumes to be fair
oh they are yeah yeah they're all
dressed up as what they want to be when
they grow up which she wants she wants
to be an anime Warrior yeah she wants to
be here she wants to be a Demon Slayer
because she wants to slay demons okay
okay I apologize then
to this fictional character
it's gonna be good
what if she just what if she like
I'd probably say something like
that yeah this could go so sideways she
like loses it and impales them both with
a massive real sword yeah yeah it's
about Jeremy's got a gun Style
third form
so uh I decided to dress up as my
favorite anime character tanjiro from
Demon Slayer that wasn't the assignments
what the [__] are you doing Heather
[Music]
sorry Mia keep going uh what's someone
take to become an anime Creator I'm skip
forward what are you guys talking about
what does this teacher needs to get away
you need to leave it oh yeah she walked
it you gotta go wait you gotta go to
where she walks in no because they act
like the president walked in video I was
able to meet
Columbus
on YouTube on a special project special
project yeah maybe it feels like Mr
Beast right snipe sister says Sniper
Wolf Hang On My Own anime series but I
haven't found the right person to collab
with until I found Mia
so we're gonna produce a show together
and I'll promote it on my channel
you're making a shielded sniper that's
so cool you're gonna be famous what are
you guys talking about
losers I think my subscribers would
disagree but thanks for making that Tick
Tock because that's how I found Mia all
right I gotta wrap this up yeah yeah we
get the idea it's inspirational I'm glad
they won't work my favorite part was
that well I'll just sum up the ending
she become a successful Creator anime
Creator and in the future she's dating
Chase and that girl what the bully walks
in for a job
oh okay I didn't see that oh
a job at the animation studio she runs I
think it's just like a secretary or
something I gotta see that Heather I
like that it's almost like it's not that
inspirational because it's kind of mean
like the ending it's like you're [__]
[__] but now I hope run our social
media
running the social media hey tell my mom
will be there at seven and I'm coming
right now for the meeting
and your first task can be making us
some coffee like she's vindictive she's
like and and then when you become
successful you'll be able to hold it
over people's head and get revenge on
Baroque unsuccessful idiots uh I can do
that I'm just kidding you can help
Runners I'm just [__] with you [__]
I'm just kidding no look she's gonna be
gracious no she just opened the social
media she just dunked on her she's like
get coffee she said just kidding you
don't have to do she goes I'm just
kidding get the [__] out humiliating
get out of myself you're pretty good at
that oh another burn
sorry about that by the way
but that sounds good great HR we'll get
you started oh and Mia
thank you again
I'm gonna puke this is so just plotting
something
miserable there's Chase bruh they're
shooting this out of like a dentist
office
oh thanks honey oh he is so hot right
they had a Sniper Wolf this is this
casual wardrobe video games okay all
right there it is uh we love we love a
good Revenge story
all right guys that's it for today thank
you everybody for being here we love you
all so very much tomorrow morning we'll
be back for leftovers
me and Hassan will be sitting here
locked in
uh Mortal Kombat except not physical and
not really combat
[Music]
right is that good I'm sure yeah
and we got some good stuff to talk about
tomorrow
in particular uh Crowder's life
continues to just
crumble is very very enjoyable uh his um
his analytics somebody did an analysis
on his views and it is brutal it's so
bad he's like he's dead in the water so
that's good news all right so we'll see
you guys tomorrow and then we'll be back
on Friday for after dark but until then
have a beautiful evening love you guys
so much and we'll see you tomorrow
it's a rainy day out here in Los Angeles
[Music]